Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu UKW, Ausgabe sechsundvi
sich unsere kleine Welt muss mal wieder beobachtet werden in einem Korona Weekly und das machen wir natürlich auch, weil ist ja Freitag und das hat sich jetzt hier so ein bisschen eingespielt als der optimale
Zeitpunkt, die Zahlen zusammenzufegen und ich sage hallo zu Pavel, hallo.
Ja ist äh einiges passiert wieder diese Woche und äh neue Erkenntnislagen, neue äh Zahlen, Reihen und besonders viel äh Feedback. Wir wollen versuchen heute mal ein bisschen mehr von eurem Feedback auch einzubauen.
Wo's äh passt und wo wir in der Lage waren, dann auch die umfangreichen Informationen, die ihr da liefert, äh halbwegs in das einzubauen, was wir so.
Hier so vorbereitet haben. Ja aber ich denke erstmal fangen wir direkt an mit dem Zahlensalat.
Diesmal blicken wir erstmal außerhalb.
Genau, vielleicht noch das Datum, genau, Freitag der dreizehnte elfte.
Okay, Freitag der dreizehnte mit neuen Diopszahlen.
Mhm. Genau. Ja, heute mal eine etwas andere Reihenfolge sozusagen. Der Zoom von
der Welt auf die einzelnen Kontinente und dann ja nach Europa, nach Deutschland und nach Berlin, äh was die Zahlen.
Angeht und was die Welt angeht äh so.
Geht der Anstieg weltweit gerade na ja leicht zurück beziehungsweise stagniert. Also es steigt jetzt nicht mehr so grade nicht so stark an äh auf der Welt,
der Grund dafür ist wiederum, dass in Europa sowohl in der EU als auch,
Gesamteuropa die Zahlen zurückgehen und ansonsten im Rest der Welt mit Ausnahme jetzt der USA.
Ihr nicht so viel los ist, also was jetzt den Anstieg an Neuinfektionen angeht, sodass,
sagen gerade quasi die Entwicklung in Europa so ein bisschen ja den Trend äh setzt äh oder beeinflusst, den wir
weltweit sehen
und im Vergleich der Kontinente auch, kann man sagen, so gut am wenigsten in Australien äh los, aber das ist halt auch ein Sonderfall, das ist halt ein relativ wenig bevölkerter,
Kontinent, aber ja Australien nicht viel los
Afrika ähm ja auch nicht viel los, Asien
auch nicht viel los. Äh Südafrika, Indien, zwar schon mehr, aber liegt alles sang unter dem Welt äh Durchschnitt,
und ähm ja.
Amerika als Ganzes sind die Zahlen auch jetzt seit August äh immer weiter runter gegangen. Da kommt's zwar immer wieder zu kleineren Ausbrüchen jetzt,
Ähm ja und dann äh Nordamerika, so liegt halt zweieinhalb Mal äh über dem.
Weltdurchschnitt gerade und hat auch einen massiven Anstieg, wobei da der Großteil eben auf die USA äh zurückgeht
die äh
Ja jetzt wieder Europa überflügelt hat, zwar noch nicht die EU bei den Neuerkrankungen, aber jetzt genau mitten zwischen Europa und der EU liegt aber während Europa jetzt gerade die Kurve,
zu kriegen scheint, äh ist es äh bei den USA nicht der Fall, da ist
nichts zu sehen, äh dass da Ruhe eintritt. Ja und ansonsten ist es jetzt interessant, wenn man jetzt.
Auf Europa guckt, dann äh kann man äh ganz gut sehen, so die Länder, die uns so ein bisschen voraus sind, die halt ihren Ausbruch hatten.
Und in der Regel, ja, nein, eigentlich alle einen Logdown hatten.
In der Regel einen deutlich schärferen Lokdown als der den wir hatten und,
wenn man da in die Ländergruppe guckt, äh, sind es Belgien und Tschechien, die es geschafft haben, die Zahlen jetzt deutlich zu reduzieren. In Spanien gehen die Zahlen auch runter
Irland hat es auch geschafft und.
Israel ist zwar jetzt nicht Europa, aber ist auch ein ganz gutes Beispiel, weil die eben noch ein paar Wochen früher dran waren mit ihrer,
zweiten großen Welle und man da vielleicht auch so ein paar Dinge rausziehen.
Kann. Was man.
Aus Israel, vielleicht lernen kann ist erstmal dass wenn man sich die Zahlen anguckt dann hatte Israel so.
Im Juni einen fast ähnlichen Verlauf bei der Idenzidenz, wie wir jetzt gerade haben, so fast sieht fast identisch
aus, dann kam das auch so ein bisschen zum Stillstand und die Zahlen gingen etwas runter. So, für.
Drei Wochen ungefähr sah es so aus, als wäre es unter Kontrolle, aber die Zahlen gingen nicht wirklich stark runter, sondern blieben mehr oder weniger auf dem.
Niveau, um dann halt im zweiten Anlauf äh richtig zu.
Explodieren, also mit also man darf vielleicht rausziehen kann ist, wenn wir die Zahlen,
nicht deutlich runterkriegen, ist es nur eine Frage der Zeit, bei den Institzen äh
da reicht dann ein, zwei Wochen schlechtes Wetter wahrscheinlich und es äh explodiert dann nochmal komplett. Also insofern ja, dass vielleicht eine Lehre, die man aus Israel ziehen kann.
Zweite Lehre, die man so draus ziehen kann, dass es in Israel ungefähr drei Wochen gedauert hat.
Bis die Zahlen wieder auf der Ebene waren, wo sie waren.
Als der Lokdown begonnen hatte. Und das ist so ein allgemeines Muster, aber es sind nicht immer drei Wochen, es kann auch schneller gehen, so.
In Tschechien hat man's in zwei Wochen geschafft runterzugehen, aber mit einem auch ziemlich krassen Blockdown.
Ja Belgien ungefähr,
gleiche auch relativ schnell wobei es da vier Wochen gedauert hat, aber in Belgien ist die Schwierigkeit,
Belgien gab es halt regional unterschiedliche Verschärfungen und zwar am sechsten, neunten, zehnten zwölften, dreizehnten, vierzehnten, fünfzehnten, neunzehnten, dreiundzwanzigsten, vierundzwanzigsten, fünfundzwanzigsten, siebenundzwanzigsten Oktober
wurde überall irgendwas verschärft. Am neunundzwanzigsten wurde das für ganz Belgien vereinheitlicht und am zweiten November nochmal verschärft und,
dann hat's eben
ja wie gesagt vier Wochen gedauert in Belgien, aber man kann aufgrund dieser dieser uneinheitlichen Verschärfungen nicht genau sagen, wann jetzt der Lokdown eigentlich begonnen hat
so, aber es sieht eher so aus, als wenn man ein bisschen übers Ziel hinausgeschossen ist beim Blockdown, weil
man auch zu einem Zeitpunkt äh nochmal verschärft hat, wo die Zahlen dann eigentlich schon äh sagen den Trend nach unten äh gemacht haben.
Was man halt dann eher bei uns möchte, ist dass sich das nicht so.
Entwickelt wie in Israel, sondern wenn wir uns an jemanden Beispiel nehmen, dann vielleicht eher an,
Irland, wie gesagt, Fuß, Fuß einfach funktioniert hat, wo die Kurve so ähnlich aussieht wie bei uns und also vom Piek hat es.
Ungefähr dann vier Wochen gedauert, ja.
Vier Wochen vom vom Peak äh bis ähm sagen wir wieder unter fünfzig war.
Bevor er sich jetzt irgendeiner äh wundert, sollte man nochmal sagen, wir vergleichen das jetzt hier immer relativ zur Bevölkerungsmenge, ne? Also es sind jetzt keine absoluten Zahlen, sondern es ist jetzt wirklich so per Million.
Weil ansonsten macht's halt eher wenig Sinn, wenn man muss man halt ständig irgendwelche Korrekturfaktoren ein äh rechnen, also deswegen und.
Aber wenn du sagst, Irland ist bei fünfzig, dann reden wir halt nicht von dieser fünfzig auf hunderttausend Institenz an. Du beziehst dich jetzt auf fünfzig pro Million, also eher eine fünfer Inzidenz.
Ja, das ist äh äh nee, wie gesagt, das ist
äh äh aber das ist wiederum dann pro Tag, also es sind diese sieben äh Zehntel, die man dann rechnen muss, beziehungsweise zehn Siebte, weil es ist dann also für diese fünfzig, die wir haben, ist halt pro Zehntausend
und pro Woche und in den Grafen, die ich auch getwittert habe, die man bei
Auerworld in Detak riecht, sind es zwar pro Million, aber der Durchschnitt pro Tag. Sei es um auf die Woche zu kommen,
den Wert mal sieben nehmen und dann durch zehn. Also ungefähr entspricht in dem Graphen siebzig entspricht äh ungefähr äh den fünfzig.
Okay. Ja.
So. Genau, also Irland ist der Benchmark mit anderen äh Worten. Also.
Irland würde ich sagen, zeigt so ein bisschen, wie es eigentlich laufen sollte oder wie es wo man sagen könnte, okay, wenn's bei uns so läuft wie in Irland, dann äh ja, ist es gut ge.
Aber wenn ich mir jetzt die Kurven so anschaue, äh die die Irlandkurve, dann sind sie also dann sehr viel schneller wieder nach unten abgebogen. Also die Maßnahmen haben dann äh eine schnelle Umkehr gehabt und äh
der na ja der Kurvenverlauf, den ich dann hier für Deutschland im Vergleich sehe, ist sehr viel langgestreckter, also man merkt
dass die Maßnahmen nicht so massiv sind.
Na ja, wir sind äh also das wissen wir halt noch nicht. Wir wissen noch nicht, wo der Piek liegt, weil wir hatten ja,
heute gut kommen wir später noch zu, ja neu, gerade nochmal neue Rekord äh Werte in Deutschland, insofern wissen wir es nicht, aber äh ja.
Eigentlich müssten die Maßnahmen äh jetzt greifen, aber dazu ich gerne dann nochmal später.
Gibt noch ein paar schlechtere Beispiele auf jeden Fall erstmal internation.
Eingehen. Ja ähm.
Was man ähm also auch, das war jetzt sozusagen die die Gruppe derer, die es.
Zwar nicht notwendigerweise hinter sich haben, aber die zumindest äh ja in den Lokdown gegangen sind und wo die Zahlen äh.
Deutlich und ganz klar nach unten gegangen sind und wo sie sagen, unter die Werte gefallen sind, äh wo sie waren, als man in Lokdown ausgerufen hat.
Dann gibt's eine ganze Reihe von Ländern, wo es so ein bisschen, wo man so einen leichten Knick äh schon sehen kann, aber wo man noch nicht,
Ganz sicher ist und dann gibt's Österreich. Ähm.
Äh
Also ja, Österreich und Italien nicht ganz so stark, aber äh Litauen geht äh auch äh sagen wir mal mit einer ähnlichen Steigung nach oben äh wie
Österreich ähm Schweden ist so ein bisschen wie Deutschland allerdings auf einem ungefähr doppelt so hohem Niveau.
Ja, uke hatte äh lange Zeit jetzt, also.
Drei, vier Wochen, die Zahlen, also die Neuerkrankungen einigermaßen konstant gehalten, aber da zieht's jetzt auch nach oben. Äh Kosovo
breitet sich alles ganz gut aus und Deutschland in dem Vergleich
ist halt so sehr ähnlich mit Griechenland und der Ukraine.
So, was die aktuellen Institzen und den Anstieg äh angeht. Wobei diese Vergleiche, natürlich muss man auch dazu sagen, immer schwierig sind, weil die Länder ein anderes Testregime fahren und andere Dunkelziffer haben. Insofern.
Kann das halt ganz anders liegen, aber äh ja, von der Dynamik her auf jeden Fall und von dem, was berichtet wird.
Bessere Zahlen haben wir halt nicht sind wir äh ja äh auf den ähnlichen Pfad oder fast dem gleichen Pfad wie Griechenland und ähm.
Die Ukraine. Ja und dann war natürlich, weil Litauen so abgeht, ist interessanterweise, dass aber Lettland.
Istland äh deutlich drunter liegen. Das wäre also auch nochmal interessant zu sehen, was eigentlich in Litauen anders ist oder anders gelaufen ist als äh in den anderen beiden baltischen Ländern. Ich hatte da jetzt äh.
Ja äh noch nicht reingeguckt, aber vielleicht weiß ja jemand von den Hörern auch Genaueres äh darüber, was da der Unterschied.
Sein könnte.
Wir heilen uns ja jetzt auch gerade so ein bisschen an deinen frisch geposteten Überblick auf Twitter entlang und,
Ich wundere mich so ein bisschen, dass du die Schweizer nicht in deiner Liste mit drin hast. Weil da ist auch gerade eine Menge los.
Ja aber die Schweiz gehörte zu der Gruppe drei.
Die jetzt schon sagen keinen Anstieg mehr zu verzeichnen hat.
Wo es noch nicht ganz klar ist, äh ob sie schon durch sind oder nicht. Die haben halt, könnte sein, dass die Schweiz ihren Piek äh auch schon hinter sich hat, aber ähm ja.
Ähm ist halt noch nicht wieder runter auf äh ich habe also den Schnitt bei den sagen Ländern, die von denen wir was lernen können, äh habe ich halt diejenigen genommen, wo,
man wenigstens runter war auf Werte zu dem Zeitpunkt wo man den Lokdown begonnen hatte.
Ja, mir ist nur gerade aufgefallen, dass wir einfach äh derzeit dafür, dass dass wir eigentlich ein deutsch
sprachigen Zyröhrerkreis haben, eigentlich die Situation in Österreich und auch in der Schweiz, insbesondere bisher ein wenig ignoriert haben, das ist äh vielleicht etwas, was wir mal ab
stellen sollten.
Ja? Also die, wie gesagt, die Schweiz äh.
Steht besser da als Österreich derzeit äh und äh ja stand äh aber in absoluten äh Zahlen.
Nicht so gut aber könnte den den Peak auch schon überschritten haben so. Also sie ist weiter als Deutschland jedenfalls.
Ähm ja Stichwort Deutschland.
Ja.
Ähm genau.
Was ist denn bei uns los? Wir haben in einer eine sehr hohe äh Neuinfektionszahl äh bekommen, glaube ich, für heute.
Neuer neuer Rekord. Die Zahl ist aber auch äh sag mal von den Ziffern her äh eine ziemlich krasse Zahl. Dreiundzwanzigtausendfünfhundertzweiundvierzig.
Vorne die.
Glaubt.
Wir haben also vorne die dreiundzwanzig. Hinten die zweiundvierzig und in der Mitte dann die fünf. Also das ist irgendwie also ja best, also krassere fünfstellige Zahl glaube ich äh.
Kann man sich so nicht ausdenken.
Und das am Freitag, dem dreizehnten, aber ja, gut, ist Zufall, aber.
Bisschen Zahlenmagieser erlaubt.
Genau. Ja und äh wir hatten also sowohl in absoluten Zahlen heute den Rekord.
Als auch aber beim sieben Tagesdurchschnitt, der liegt jetzt knapp bei neunzehntausend pro Tag.
Heißt in den letzten sieben Tagen hundertfünfunddreißigtausend.
Neu infiziert und wenn man sich das überlegt, wie wir so bei der ersten Welle so äh auf die chinesischen achtzigtausend geguckt haben, ob wir auch, ob wir besser sind vielleicht als die Chinesen, ja.
Und wenn man dann aber äh sich äh auch noch überlegt, dass wir ja.
In der Gesamtzahl, jetzt wo, irgendwo bei siebenhundert irgendwas tausend liegen, ist es natürlich krass, dass in der letzten, in den letzten sieben Tagen.
Über hunderttausend dazu gekommen sind. Ja, im Vergleich zu jetzt der gesamten Epidemie und einschließlich der ersten Welle, die ja äh auch nicht ohne Wagut.
Andere Dunkelziffer, aber trotzdem, das sind nach wie vor dann die die öffentlichen Zahlen.
Vor allem China hat ja nun auch noch ein paar mehr Einwohner in Deutschland. Also das äh ist überhaupt gar kein Vergleich mehr, aber da kommen wir auch gleich äh nachher noch zu zu diesem ganzen internationalen Blick.
Vielleicht noch zwei äh Dinge jetzt zu sagen bei Deutschland als Zeit äh Reihe oder die zeitliche Entwicklung betrachtet. Man sieht deutlich aber, dass mit jedem Tag äh so der sieben Tages R.
Wert zurückgeht.
Und wir liegen jetzt aber immer noch über eins bei eins Komma null fünf bis eins Komma null acht.
So, das ist die das erste Ding.
Wobei, jetzt können wir vielleicht auch einen kleinen äh Exkurs äh machen äh nochmal an der Stelle zum,
RWT in Deutschland oder möchtest du das lieber, dass wir's später besprechen.
Können wir gerne machen, also warum warum nicht? Ja, lass uns über den Ehrwert reden. Das äh gibt ja Zweifel am R.
Genau, ich versuch's halt ganz kurz zu machen, aber es ist halt wichtig.
Sagen, äh um auch den Vergleich jetzt, ich sage mal, zwischen meinem R-Wert und dem RKI erwert, der überall veröffentlicht äh wird, klar zu machen.
Ich bin irgendwann dazu übergegangen den RWT aus den gemeldeten.
Oder aus den veröffentlichten Zahlen äh und zwar basierend auf dem Veröffentlichungsdatum ähm zu berechnen,
Das heißt, wenn es heute dreiundzwanzigtausendfünfhundertzweiundvierzig neue Infektionen.
Gab, dann es geht dieser Wert zu sagen für heute in den RW,
ein, in meinen R wird, das heißt man kann dann auch ganz klar sagen, okay, wenn der RWT über eins ist, dann sind die veröffentlichten.
Täglichen Zahlen auch tatsächlich gestiegen. Und wenn da unter eins ist, sind sie auch gefallen. Außerdem alles immer mindestens auf sieben Tage gemittelt, weil unter sieben Tage macht's einfach gar keinen Sinn.
Bei den halt wöchentlichen Schwankungen, das heißt alles unter sieben Tagen kann man knicken. Man kann vielleicht noch manchmal gucken, okay, wie war denn der Wert vor sieben Tagen? War der dann höher oder niedriger,
aber auch dass es nicht ganz unproblematisch, insofern sieben Tagesschnitt so,
Problem natürlich mit meinem Ehrwert ist, wenn ich auch noch den sieben Tagesschnitt nehme, dann hinkt der nicht nur um die zehn Tage hinter dem Infektionsgeschehen hinterher oder zwölf Tage, die es dauert.
Von der Erkrankung bis zur Mildung, sondern nochmal, wenn man mindestens dreieinhalb Tage ähm sagen, wenn ich die Mitte von den sieben Tagen nehme, das heißt, mein Airwert läuft also.
Dem Infektionsgeschehen sehr weit hinterher. Dafür ist es halt ganz einfach nachvollziehbar und berechenbar und.
Ich kann's in Korrelation mit den täglich gemeldeten Zahlen setzen. So, das ist das eine Ding, was das RKI macht, aber.
Ist, damit sie quasi zeitlich, also näher am Puls der Zeit sind, nehmen sie ähm.
Das Meldedatum beim Gesundheitsamt, beziehungsweise das Erkrankungsdatum und wenn es wenn es angegeben wurde, wenn nicht, wird dann sagen synthetisch, nun.
Äh einen oder ein Infektionsdatum zurückgerechnet und dann wird.
In die Zukunft.
Extra poliert, also wird quasi eine Vorhersage gemacht und eine Vorhersage deshalb, weil natürlich die Meldungen erst verspätet eintreffen beim,
RKI, also auch das so aber einen Teil der Meldungen trifft halt relativ schnell, also zwanzig bis dreißig Prozent treffen halt am selben Tag,
ein und der Rest so im Laufe der nächsten vierzehn Tage ungefähr,
Jetzt kann man hingehen oder das RKI geht halt hin und sagt, okay, wir wissen jetzt in den letzten zwei, drei Tagen sind jetzt, müssten jetzt eigentlich so dreißig, vierzig, fünfzig Prozent der Meldungen eingegangen sein
noch kommen werden und deswegen rechnen wir jetzt.
Auf Basis dieser Werte hoch, wie viel noch kommen werden in den nächsten zehn Tagen und berechnen daraus den RWT. So,
Es geht halt meistens auch ganz okay, aber dass sie quasi in die Zukunft blicken.
Geht das nicht immer auf, weil plötzlich ändert sich irgendwas, das Wetter ändert sich oder das,
Testregime ändert sich oder es gibt einen Logdown,
und plötzlich funktionieren diese ganzen Statistiken nicht mehr. Also ich habe das versucht sozusagen auch mit mal mit eigenen Mitteln hinzukriegen und zu machen und habe aber gesehen, okay
das geht eine Zeit lang gut, aber wenn irgendwas Neues passiert oder wenn sich irgendwas ändert, dann geht's halt nicht mehr gut und äh dann.
Steht man halt da und hört halt seit einer Woche, dass.
Des R beim RKI unter eins gefallen ist, aber täglich werden äh äh höhere Zahlen vermeldet und da fragt man sich, äh wie passt denn das jetzt zusammen.
So und es passt eben genau so zusammen, dass das RKI R, also.
RWT des RKI eben nicht.
Auf den veröffentlichungsdaten basiert, äh sondern eben auf äh Melde
Erkrankungsinfektionsdaten, die dann hochgerechnet werden und diese Prognosen sind dann eben manchmal falsch.
Und vor allem bisschen optimistischer als als klingt optimistischer.
Ja in der Regel komischerweise klingen sie auch äh ähm,
meist optimistischer, ich hab das jetzt nicht untersucht, ich hab nur gehört, dass Leute, die sich das angeguckt haben, festgestellt haben, dass es wohl auch systematisch der Ehrwert eher nach unten
abweicht, der vom RKI. So und deswegen habe ich mir dann irgendwann gesagt, ich will's halt einfach haben.
So, ich will halt diesen Wert haben, der halt mit der Kurve korrespondiert ähm von den täglich gemeldeten Zahlen.
Was ist denn jetzt dein aktueller R, den du so errechnest.
Ja, ich habe, ich wende außerdem drei verschiedene Rechen.
An, damit ich sehe, in wie weit das noch gegenüber jetzt Mittelwertbildung und so
da gibt's nämlich dann welche die scharf die schneller anschlagen und die weniger schnell, sodass ich halt dann sehen kann okay
aber im Moment liegen sie alle drei Rechenmethoden extrem nah beieinander und wir liegen bei eins Komma null fünf bis eins Komma null acht.
Deutschlandweit für den RWT. Ja.
Immer noch zu viel.
Immer noch zu viel, definitiv. So, was man aber außerdem auch noch sehen kann an meinem kombinierten Chart.
Da gibt's dann gleichzeitig auch noch die sieben Tage äh Kurve äh für die Toten.
So und die entwickelt sich jetzt seit drei Wochen äh läuft die fast parallel mit den Infektionskurve, aber halt zwölf bis dreizehn Tage hinterher.
Und so äh und die ist um den Faktor hundert ähm.
Vergrößert, aber wenn man das macht, sieht man, dass die gerade fast parallel laufen
und das bedeutet halt, dass man dann sehen kann, wenn die halt zwölf bis dreizehn Tage hinterher läuft
ähm kann man halt jetzt schon sagen, dass wir eben äh voraussichtlich bei den bei zweihundert Toten im Sieben-Tagesschnitt ankommen werden in.
Zwölf bis dreizehn Tagen, wenn das jetzt der Peak war, was noch nicht sicher ist. Ja, das heißt ähm.
Ja
und zweihundert Tote hat gerade jemand auch auf Twitter bemerkt, es ist so ein voll besetzter Kurzstreckenflieger pro Tag so wenn
jede Woche jeden Tag irgendwo ein Flugzeug mit zweihundert Menschen abstürzen würde, hätte das glaube ich nochmal eine ganz,
andere Dringlichkeit, äh was hier.
Komischerweise, ne?
Weiß, kann das jetzt nicht vergleichen, aber immerhin zweihundert Menschenleben sind zweihundert Menschenleben. So.
Kann man, also die Show miteinander vergleichen, ne? Aber es ist dann halt weniger äh die Zahl, die äh selbst beklagt wird, sondern es ist halt immer nur dieser Aufreger, um den Absturz als solche, ne?
Ja, leider muss man sagen, das ist halt überwiegend.
Ältere Menschen sind und werden ganz offensichtlich aber äh dann doch am Ende des Tages man sagt, na ja gut, bei den älteren Menschen.
Ist es halt jetzt nicht ganz so schlimm, wenn uns sagen wir jetzt die am schlimmsten wär's, wenn uns jetzt die fünfundzwanzigjährigen,
Dreißigjährigen Hochschulabsolventen.
In äh wichtigen, also in die teuer ausgebildet sind, wenn die halt massiv betroffen äh äh wären oder natürlich auch äh Kinder oder Jugendliche so.
Oder auch ja mein Familienväter. Ähm so aber ähm.
Es bleibt ein schwieriger Vergleich. Äh ich meine es würde ja Umkehrschluss bedeuten, dass jetzt irgendwie ältere Leute für die Gesellschaft keinen Wert haben, das ist natürlich auch totaler Unsinn.
Ne, aber die, also die Wahrnehmung scheint mir eine andere.
Ja, die Wahrnehmung ist ist äh sicherlich eine andere oder zumindest hat man den Eindruck, dass sie eine andere ist, ne. Es ist halt bloß nicht so, ne?
Weil sonst wäre sonst wie gesagt, wenn man's jetzt vergleicht mit dem Flieger, sonst wäre hier gerade eine ganz nochmal eine ganz anderes Maß an Panik am Start, wobei man sagen kann, gut äh,
Es ist schon so mittelmittelviel Panik gerade. Ähm na ja ähm.
Ja
So viel zum Ehrwert erstmal.
So viel zum zum RWT und äh und was ich dann auch noch mache, ist immer, dass ich sagen auch einen R-Wert nach,
für die Zahl der Toten äh berechne er, sondern vergleichswert
äh ob jetzt die Zahl der Toten stärker oder weniger ansteigt, als jetzt die Zahl der Infizierten und da muss man sagen ist der Ehrwert äh für
die Toten sinkt auch, liegt aber eher in der Größenordnung um eins Komma vier. Ah, also deutlich höher, das heißt.
Die Zahl der Toten steigt also höher äh an. Das heißt, höher wahrscheinlich deutlich noch über die zweihundert auch ausschießen.
Ja bei den Toten.
Tja OK sagt dann nochmal dann was zu Berlin vielleicht abschließend.
Ja, vielleicht noch ganz kurz äh dein Blick auf die auf die anderen Länder so wo wir sagen gut.
Dreißig, also Bayern, Bayern dominiert ähm und,
ähm ja ansonsten im direkten, also im Ländersummenvergleich, so Sachsen vor Berlin, Bayern, Hessen, NRW, Saarland und Hamburg, da sind sozusagen die.
Über dem Bundesdurchschnitt liegen Mecklenburg-Vorpommern als einziges Land unter fünfzig und,
fallenden Zahlen und in Bremen fallen die Zahlen auch
So, aber so Tabellenführer, so auf Platz eins der Risikoliste ist äh einen Brandenburger Landkreis Spree-Neiße. Ist nicht dazu gekommen, zu gucken, was da los ist, aber
das spricht, könnte so ein bisschen dafür sprechen, dass es jetzt in Brandenburg irgendwie verspätet auch losgehen
könnte. Falls das nicht irgendwie einen Ausbruch in einem Heim ist oder so, das wäre auch möglich. Ja, ansonsten.
Berlin R mig sind wir jetzt auch da, wo wir beim Bund sind irgendwo.
Wobei wir auch nie so hoch waren, aber es ist auch ganz langsam zurückgegangen. Wir hatten aber heute einen richtig fetten Sprung nochmal bei.
Neu infizierten tausendneunhundertsechzig heute. Das ist äh ja, hat nochmal den bisherigen.
Rekord deutlich getopt und äh haben deswegen halt auch bei den äh sieben Tage äh Durchschnitt.
Ja fünfundfünfzig,
Den haben wir also dann irgendwie fast fast verdoppelt, äh, sagen im Piek jetzt, also im doppelt so hohen Piek gerade. Ähm, Zahl der Toten geht.
Eigentlich im Moment, aber es ist halt durch.
Sind wir bei Berlin schon in einem Bereich, wo es halt sehr verrauscht wird, wo es halt Sprünge äh gibt.
Und die im Moment steigt die Zahl der Toten noch nicht so stark an wie in in Berlin wie.
Rest des Landes muss man sagen. Ähm ja und bei den Bezirken allerdings.
Gibt's halt die äh interessante Überraschung, das jetzt in Friedrichshain-Kreuzberg und Neukölln und auch in Spandau.
Aber vor allem Kreuzberg und Neukölln fallen jetzt die Neuinfektionen und Mitte ist jetzt der mit Abstand gefährlichste Bezirk.
Und auch in Reinickendorf sind noch starke Anstiege, aber ja.
Gehen die Zahlen zurück oder es wird niemand mehr getestet dort war nicht genügend Leute werden getestet, das kann natürlich auch alles sein.
Und.
Ansonsten nochmal für Berlin fällt mir auch immer die sieben Tage Institut nach Altersgruppen mehr oder weniger automatisch.
Raus gerade und ja.
Ist nach wie vor jetzt die fünfzehn bis vierunddreißigjährigen wo es zwar auch stagniert, das heißt eigentlich stagniert's überall.
Außer bei den über Achtzigjährigen,
da äh sind die Institzen deutlich gefallen. Zum Glück muss man sagen, das heißt Berlin schafft es, die Alten gerade ein bisschen besser zu schützen als den Rest der Bevölkerung, könnte man sagen.
Und es gibt Hinweise, aber die möchte ich nochmal extra nachgehen, dass jetzt in der Altersgruppe fünf zehn bis zwanzig,
die ich hier jetzt aber nicht bei den aktuellen RKI-Daten habe, sondern die sind immer nur ein bisschen älter.
Aber da scheint sich halt bei den älteren Schülern äh äh richtig was zu entwickeln, also.
Die sind in einigen Bezirken, die mittlerweile äh am stärksten Betroffene Altersgruppe von allen.
Während es bisher eher so die zwanzig bis Dreißigjährigen waren oder auch Berlin weit so die zwanzig bis Dreißigjährigen scheint sich das äh jetzt äh ja die fünfzehn bis zwanzigjährigen, also die älteren Schüler vor allem
das mitzubringen. Während ja die im Bereich fünf bis vierzehn, also Grundschüler und.
Ja bis ich sage mal bis zehnte Klasse ungefähr.
Ist unauffällig bei den äh Institzen.
Ja die bewegt sich so im Mittelbereich und unterscheidet sich jetzt nicht von den sechzig bis neunundsiebzigjährigen.
Und äh oder dem fünfunddreißig bis neunundfünfzigjährigen so.
Das heißt ähm irgendwas ist da anders äh und.
Frage ist, ist das jetzt äh gibt es systematisch da einen anderen Schulunterricht oder sind's dann doch nicht wirklich die Schulen, sondern oder die Tatsache, also der Schulunterricht
sondern eher das dann gemeinsam abhängen oder unklar. So irgendwelche Theorien dazu.
Wir haben gerade zu Schulen und in Berlin auch noch äh Feedback bekommen. Da gehe ich gleich nochmal drauf äh äh ein. Ich wollte nochmal äh eine andere Sache äh herausstellen. Ich habe mir nämlich deine Tabelle mal äh genommen und
sortil die mal nach was anderem. Ich habe das glaube ich in der letzten Sendung schon mal kurz äh gemacht, aber finde das jetzt ein zunehmendem Maße interessant, einfach um sich mal die Zahlen zu vergegenwärtigen. Und zwar sortiere ich die Tabelle einfach mal nach
Fälle je einhunderttausend total, ne? Wo man also mal wirklich sehen kann wie viel ist in einem Landkreis eigentlich mittlerweile die komplette Pandemie über passiert? Wie viele Leute haben sich eigentlich insgesamt
infiziert.
Und äh halt in Relation zu zu der äh Einwohnerzahl und äh ja, da gibt's einen einsamen Spitzenreiter, nämlich den Landkreis Tirschenreuth in Bayern, der ist,
irgendwie am laufenden Meter oben vertreten gewesen. Wenn man sich das auf der Landkarte anschaut, das ist einfach dörflich geprägt, da ist irgendwie kein.
Nichts Großes so, also der Ort Hirschenreuth scheint mir da das Größte zu sein. Das ist eigentlich auch nur so eine Kleinstadt. Keine Ahnung, was da abgeht,
Aber die haben bisher zweitausendzweihunderteinundsechzig Fälle je einhunderttausend oder anders ausgedrückt, zwei.
Zwei Prozent der gesamten Bevölkerung haben sich infiziert, also nachgewiesener Maßen infiziert.
Mhm.
Da wir mindestens von zwei äh bis vielleicht sogar vier oder sechs äh an Dunkelziffer ausgehen können, sind's wahrscheinlich eher dann äh fünftausendachttausend äh
Ähm.
Also fünf bis acht Prozent. Das schon äh ziemlich krass, ne?
Wenn man dann die äh also in dieser Zweitausender äh Kategorie ist übrigens auch Neukölln vertreten, also auch im Stadtteil Neukölln. Sind schon zwei Prozent der Bevölkerung nachgewiesenermaßen mit dem Chrona-Virus infiziert wo.
Rosenheim in Bayern ist auch noch da und zwar sowohl der Stadtkreis als auch der Landkreis, also da geht's äh richtig zur Sache. Dann kommen noch so ein paar andere äh im Wesentlichen eigentlich alles in Bayern und in Berlin. Ja, also,
äh so, dann Cloppenburg ist dann irgendwie erst der Erste, der irgendwie auf Platz zehn dann äh folgt und so geht das dann immer weiter. Wenn man jetzt mal das ganze nach Todesfällen je hundert.
Ja, das hätte ich jetzt nämlich auch gemacht. Mhm.
Ja, da gibt's äh auch einen ganz klaren äh Spitzenreiter und das ist auch wieder Tirschenreuth, also in Tirschenreuth wird nicht nur infunziert, sondern da wird auch ordentlich gestorben. Und da sind sie auch so richtig äh weit vorne mit
einhundertsiebenundneunzig, also ungefähr so zwei Promill der Bevölkerung sind da bereits äh nachweislich am Corona Virus äh verstorben. Das ist sehr, sehr, sehr viel. Also der Platz zwei ist dann
brauchen Bayern, aber in Straubing
bei der Hälfte davon. Platz drei Rosenheim hat nur achtzig im Verhältnis zu diesen zweihundert und dann geht's langsam zurück. Also ich hab keine Ahnung was da in Tirschenrollt äh geht, ob das jetzt eine besonders
kontaktfreudige, sehr alte Bevölkerung ist, weiß nichts über Tirschenreuth, es
kenne das auch erst seitdem sie dieser Tabelle auftaucht, aber das ist auf jeden Fall so der der böse Landkreis in Deutschland. Ganz klar.
Also die waren wahrscheinlich auch in der ersten Welle hart getroffen. Das Ding ist, dass wir die Toten aus der
neuen zweiten Welle äh noch nicht sehen, ne? Sei es sehr interessant, wenn wir uns das jetzt in einem Monat ungefähr nochmal ansehen, äh wie sich denn dann äh diese Tabelle verändert hat und,
prognostiziere jetzt schon mal,
die Tabelle anders aussehen wird und äh dass dann Berlin das bisher in der Tabelle, was die Todesfälle äh angeht, dann eher ziemlich weit hinten ranfiert, beziehungsweise die Berliner Bezirke.
Ich hab jetzt hier und.
Da muss man ewig scrollen bis da mal was mit Berlin kommt. Ja ja es ist ganz weit hinten.
Also es ist so irgendwie in der Mitte, also Neukölln ist da ist hat einen Wert von siebzehn.
Bisher, ja? Äh, als schlimmster Bezirk, das heißt, es ist zehn Mal weniger.
So, obwohl es heißt in Neukölln könnte das dicke Ende noch kommen.
Und in vielen anderen Landkreisen.
Die Bösen dann Kreise.
Was ich auch mal gemacht hatte zwischenzeitlich ist nach äh Meldeverzögerung äh zu sortieren.
Entweder nach Mittelwert oder vielleicht nach medialen es vielleicht.
Aussagekräftiger.
Aussagekräftiger, also der Median in dem Fall ist, das heißt, soll man sagen, in in Tagen ist das alles. Ähm das heißt, dass so die Hälfte.
In dem Fall äh ungefähr liegt äh unter diesem Wert, also Hälfte der Meldung hat weniger.
Als vier Tage gebraucht im beispielsweise wenn die Zahl vier ist und die andere Hälfte hat länger gedauert und Mittelwert ist halt der Durchschnitt aus allem und da sticht nach wie vor.
Der Landkreis Görlitz irgendwie raus, weiß nicht was da.
Passiert ist, aber ich habe übrigens.
'ne kleine Änderung jetzt gemacht bei der Meldeverzögerungsberechnung ich gucke da jetzt nur noch auf die letzten vier Wochen.
Ich habe vorher auf alle Daten geguckt von Anfang an so, aber habe mir irgendwann gesagt, gut, ich sage mal, die Meldeverzögerung von vor,
drei Monaten interessiert jetzt nicht mehr, sondern ich will wissen, äh so eigentlich wie operieren die eigentlich.
Derzeit und äh oder ja und da ist es so, dass,
sagen selbst der der Landkreis Görlitz aus irgendwelchen Gründen das notorisch langsame Hamburg schlägt und ebenso auch äh ich sage mal wenn man.
Liste guckt so Erzgebirgskreis oder ähm ja also eine ganze Menge Länder auch in Sachsen und in Brandenburg.
Waisen.
Sehr hohe Meldeverzögerung aus und das geht dann häufig auch auf jeden Fall im in Görlitz mit.
Sehr hohe Instit
und sehr hohem Wachstum einher, das heißt eigentlich liegt dann allein nur aus diesen zwei Zahlen, also Landkreis Görlitz hat jetzt eine Institanz von vierhundertvierunddreißig in den letzten sieben Tagen,
und in den sieben Tagen davor waren's zweihundertzwölf. Das heißt, es hat sich fast verdoppelt. Die Inzidenz auf einen,
Rekordwert und.
Ja und gleichzeitig haben wir halt, ja, einen Median von vier Tagen,
höher als anderswo und einen Mittelwert von fünf Komma fünf Tagen. Äh da haben wir nur in Dame Spreewald noch einen höheren Mittelwert, aber
So, das heißt, man kann jetzt auch tatsächlich an diesen Verzögerungszahlen so ein bisschen ablesen, äh dass die Gesundheitsämter einfach nicht mitkommen.
Gerade in den stark betroffenen Landkreisen, was wiederum dann darauf schließen ist, wenn man jetzt irgendwo so hohe Zahlen sieht, dass die tatsächlichen Zahlen deutlich höher sein dürften.
Gut, äh, wir sind dann auch noch darauf hingewiesen worden, man solle doch auch mal äh auf das Intensivregister äh schauen, da hat uns äh Norbert äh einen Kommentar zu geschrieben
ähm machen wir gerne mal aufs Intensivregister schauen, also Intensivregister ist ja dieses Verzeichnis, was im Prinzip sagt, wie groß ist gerade die Auslastung in den Kranken
beziehungsweise den Krankenhäusern, also den Abteilungen der Krankenhäuser, wo eben intensiv medizinisch bearbeitet wird.
Und da sehen wir halt im Wesentlichen so eine Kurve, die ja im Wesentlichen das Infektionsgeschehen auch relativ klar nachzeichnet. Also hatten wir halt in der ersten Welle glaube ich so ein Maximum von.
Zweitausendachthundertfünfzig behandelten Fällen sind wir jetzt schon bei dreitausenddreihundert, also wir haben jetzt sozusagen eine höhere,
Fallzahl, die in den Krankenhäusern, also intensiv medizinischen Bereichen aufgeschlagen ist,
und dementsprechend geht natürlich auch die Zahl der ähm Highcare Kapazitäten zurück, weil natürlich diese Leute irgendwo diese Intensivbetten auch belegen.
Sieht aber jetzt auch noch nicht ganz so aus, als äh ob wir an das Maximum.
Kommen, wobei das natürlich sich jetzt ein deutschlandweiter Wert ist und der nicht berücksichtigt, wie die Auslastung in den einzelnen,
Landkreisen aussieht. Also es ist natürlich äh erfahrungsgemäß sehr unterschiedlich. Teilweise kann das dadurch abge,
mildert werden, dass Patienten verlegt werden selbstverständlich. Aber so die Reihen absoluten Gesamtdeutschlandzahlen sagen OK also hier.
Haben wir irgendwie vierzehntausendeinhundertsechsundvierzig Belegungen.
Tausendvierhundertzweiundachtzig frei, also ungefähr zehn Prozent frei. High Care, siebentausendachthundertdrei, ist schon ganz schön viel, ne.
Aber noch viertausendneunhundertfünfzehn frei. Also noch kein Notstand, aber auch kein Grund zur Entfernung.
Es ist noch Platz auf den Intensivstationen äh so, ihr könnt also ruhig weiter feiern.
Bisschen, ja.
Ja, also da will man nicht hin, irgendwie, das ist einfach keine gute Idee so, das äh egal, wie alt man ist, äh solltet ihr euch auf jeden Fall merken, klar.
Definitiv, ja, ja. Nein, aber der, aber der Punkt ist, es sieht nicht so aus nach dem Divi-Intensivregister, als äh wenn jetzt irgendwo Notstand herrschen würde oder wenn man jetzt dann doch.
Was immer passieren kann ähm trotz aller Vorsichtsmaßnahmen.
Man sich dann doch infiziert, braucht man im Moment zumindest noch nicht die Angst äh zu haben, dass man irgendwo auf dem Flur einer Triage unterworfen äh wird und es keine Beatmungs
Geräte gibt. Also da sind wir definitiv noch nicht. Aber wir sind auch nicht so weit davon entfernt wiederum bei exponentiellen Zahlen, also wir,
würde das Ganze jetzt nicht zum äh zur Verlangsamung äh kommen.
Der Anstieg und ich habe gehört, dass aber auch die Zahl der Neueingänge äh sagen, jetzt sich stabilisiert hat, beziehungsweise leicht zurückgegangen ist, auch in den Klinik.
Leute, die da vorstellig werden, insofern könnten wir jetzt wieder nochmal mit einem blauen Auge davonkommen, wenn man.
Denn zweihundert Tote pro Tag und ähm.
Ja äh äh zigtausend Intensivpatienten nur ein blaues Auge äh nennen äh darf.
Aber ja zumindest bricht das Gesundheitssystem noch nicht zusammen und wird auch nächste Woche,
noch nicht zusammenbrechen und auch noch nicht in vierzehn Tagen und dann,
sollten die Zahlen hoffentlich wieder auf dem Weg nach unten sein, sodass wir dann erstmal dann zur hoffentlich zum zweiten Mal äh eine Katastrophe oder eine schlimmere Katastrophe abgewendet.
Haben äh und ja nur eine mittelgroße Katastrophe. Äh.
Ähm gehabt haben werden, hoffentlich.
Gut, dann kommen wir mal auf das Thema Schulen, da haben wir ähm mehrere Kommentare zu bekommen, unter anderem von Raphael
der verweist uns auf ein Modell hier in einem Berliner Gymnasium des Humboldt Gymnasium in Berlin-Tegel,
Und äh davon hatte ich glaube ich irgendwann auch mal was gehört, weil mir jetzt gar nicht so klar, dass das jetzt wirklich so läuft
Da werden tatsächlich Woche für Woche alle Schüler und Lehrer getestet, die dann selber Probenentnahme machen, das sind dann ungefähr so neunhundert, die da getestet werden, also das ist schon äh eine Menge.
Ich zitiere mal kurz hier aus dem Kommentar in einem Berliner Gymnasium, wenn wöchentlich alle Schüler und Lehrer durchgetestet. Neunhundert Proben pro Woche, zu Beginn der Testreihen vor knapp drei Monaten war nur selten eine positive Probe dabei,
Das hat sich in den vergangenen Wochen geändert. Mittlerweile haben sie jede Woche fünf bis sechs positive Tests. Damit käme man auf eine sieben Tage Institut von ungefähr sechshundert, sodass man im Vergleich zu den allgemeinen Berliner Zahlen von einem Dunkelzifferfaktor von drei Komma vier
ausgehen kann. Von dieser Größenordnung.
Geht auch der Reinickendorfer Amtsarzt aus. Eine genauere Beobachtung der Fälle in diesem Gymnasium böte auch die Chance zu ermitteln, ob sich die Schüler auch innerhalb der Schule infizieren oder lediglich außerhalb infiziert haben.
Ich hoffe, dass man diesen Versuch auch weiter durchzieht in die Gesundheitsämter werden uns diese Daten mal wieder nicht liefern. Die Amtsärzte sehen in einer genauen Kontaktverfolgung innerhalb der Schulen angesichts der hohen Fallzeilen.
Kein Sinn mehr, ja. Interessant, ne? Das, dass das da äh gemacht wird.
Sieben Tage Institut von sechshundert bei fünf Fällen von neunhundert, wie muss man das denn jetzt rechnen.
Fünfhundert beiden auf neunzigtausend und dann was hatte er gesagt für ein hm ja kommt ungefähr hin.
Das würde ja bedeuten, da ist eine Menge los, ne? Das wird ja auch allgemein äh vermutet
Ähm anderer Kommentar hier von äh von Michael Michael Böhmer, der auch diese wunderbaren ähm
Statistiken immer über die Korona Warnapp da auf Gitarr veröffentlicht
Äh er sagt, wie ihr hattet euch in dieser Ausgabe, also zur letzten Kommentar zur letzten Ausgabe, mehrfach über das Thema Schule unterhalten, diesbezüglich gibt's eine neue interessante Studie in The Lanced mit einer Analyse der einzelnen
NPIs und diese Non-Pharma-Sirtical Interventions, also alles was man sozusagen nicht medikamentös macht, um Ansteckungen zu vermeiden. Die sich deren Wirkung an hunderteinunddreißig Ländern
angeschaut hat, neben dem Verbot von öffentlichen Veranstaltungen, haben Schulschließungen, einen signifikanten Effekt auf das Infektionsgeschehen
Surprise, Surprise, will man die Schulen weiterhin offen halten, müsste man sich hier viel stärker darauf fokussieren. Schnelltest, regelmäßige Test, Hybridunterricht, Puling et cetera.
In der Konsequenz befürchte ich, dass wir mit den momentan ergriffenen Maßnahmen den Air Faktor nicht genügend senken werden können. Hinzu kommt das mit der kürzlichen Änderung des Testregimes durch das RKI und einem höheren Anteil von asymptomatischen Infektionen unter Kindern,
sich das Lagebild und damit die Dunkelziffer in den Schulen verschlechtern wird. Ja.
Das äh ist natürlich eine naheliegende Schlussfolgerung. Also.
Wir gehen auch gleich nochmal ähm auf diese ganze Frage, mit was soll man eigentlich tun ähm ein, aber ich meine, ich kenne das ja nun auch, ne? Ich meine, wie wir alle, ich halte mich jetzt irgendwie.
Raus, äh seitdem Loktor haben wir hier ist halt auch überhaupt nicht mehr unterwegs und außer einmal die Woche im Supermarkt, mache ich eigentlich nicht viel. Ich,
Pink Pong hier eigentlich immer nur zwischen der Wohnung und halb Studio hin und her und äh habe hier recht wenig Kontakt. Aber ich habe ja noch ein Kind in der Schule,
ja? Zwei genau genommen und äh lebe dann sozusagen täglich so mit dieser Situation, dass dass ich diesen,
Angriffsvektor auch überhaupt nicht groß steuern kann, ne? Also ich weiß also auch in unserer Schule sind schon Fälle aufgetreten, verschiedene Kinder in Quarantäne et cetera. Also.
Ist auf gar keinen Fall virusfrei, ne? Und das ist natürlich irgendwie weiß ich nicht.
So ein bisschen man versucht sozusagen das Richtige zu tun, aber kann an der Stelle überhaupt gar nichts machen, ne? Und begibt sich damit natürlich indirekt auch mehr in Gefahr als man möchte.
Ja geht also die Frage, die hier im Raum steht, ist halt, wie geht man mit den Schulen um, ne? Und ähm im Prinzip Michael hat's ja auch gesagt, äh.
Es müssten halt Maßnahmen ergriffen werden. Ich habe jetzt mir diese Studie diazitiert halt nicht äh durchgelesen
Aber äh es ist klar, ne? Also Schnelltests beziehungsweise überhaupt regelmäßige Tests, wie in diesem Beispiel der Umweltschule. Gut, das kann man jetzt nicht in jeder Schule machen, weil das wäre halt einfach äh würde dann einfach,
Kapazität schnell überlasten, aber ist natürlich super, wenn es so regelmäßig gemacht wird.
Ich bin mir nicht hundertprozentig sicher, was mit Hybridunterricht gemeint ist, vermutlich das Aufteilen der Klassen in in Gruppen.
Vermutlich online und offline. So, dass halt wahrscheinlich während die eine Gruppe irgendwie präsent ist, wird die andere Online unterrichtet und umgekehrt. Scheint mir jetzt.
Auch einen, zumindest, ich sage mal, einen Ansatz zu sein, was ja immer sozusagen kritisiert wird, ist beim Offlineunterricht das irgendwie die sozialen Kontakte und Korrez und Erfahrungen und so verloren gehen und,
kann mir jetzt vorstellen, dass man mit so einem Hybridunterricht ja das vielleicht ein bisschen gewährleisten kann auf der einen Seite.
Aber dann die Leute nicht so ähm eng zusammensitzen äh auf der anderen Seite.
Ja gut, ich meine, das geht natürlich davon aus, dass man in irgendeiner Form einen funktionierenden Digitalunterricht haben, ne? Also man da macht jetzt jeder seine anderen Erfahrungen, haben bei uns an der einen Schule sieht's halt einfach schlicht so aus
Ja, es gibt jetzt irgendwie die Schulcloud, da wird jetzt irgendwie seit Wochen und Monaten drüber geredet, dass hier jetzt da irgendwie äh kommen soll.
Gibt's im Prinzip wohl auch schon, aber es hätten ja noch nicht alle Eltern die Datenschutzerklärung unterschrieben. Und deswegen kann man das ja alles noch überhaupt nicht in Betrieb
So ja okay, super. Dann äh das ist so das eine, ne? Das andere ist, dass es dann sozusagen aber auch erst aktiviert wird, wenn äh,
jetzt auch so ein kompletter Lok down
angeschaltet wird, ne? Also der Gedanke jetzt schon äh in so eine Digitalbespaßung überzugehen.
Wäre ja eigentlich meine ganz sinnvolle Geschichte, weil es geht ja immer nicht nur darum, dass alle weg sind, sondern auch ein Heilsversprechen äh von solchen Fernunterrichtsmethoden ist natürlich auch das,
Kinder, die jetzt vielleicht mal zwei Wochen im Krankenhaus sind, ja? Oder aus anderen Gründen krank sind und zu Hause bleiben müssen,
auch diesen Anschluss nicht so schnell verlieren oder eben jetzt auch gerade in dieser äh Situation, dass viele dann einfach in Quarantäne geschickt werden, selbst wenn sie sich jetzt nicht,
infiziert haben, dann einfach wegbleiben, was sollen die dann machen? So, ne? Die können dann halt einfach die gute alte Methode mit irgendwelche Freunde anrufen und kannst mir mal die Hausaufgaben kopieren,
Das ist halt irgendwie nix, ne? Es muss halt einfach ohnehin äh dazu übergehen, dass man eigentlich,
Immer das Lernprogramm in dem Sinne äh online abrufen kann. Ja, das einfach Hausaufgaben stehen einfach auch im Netz
man kann sie ja gerne in der Klasse auch mitteilen, aber man schreibt sie halt einfach da rein. Da steht drin hier, was weiß ich, lies uns den den Text vor, bis dann und dann soll das und das gemacht werden
für dich aus. So. Folgendes haben wir irgendwie gelernt. Ich meine, die Lehrer haben noch ihren Lehrplan.
So, wenn sie äh die halten sich ja auch immer so gerne da dran und äh vor allem lernen sie ja, wird ja auch immer gerne alles explizit nicht getan, was da nicht drinsteht. So. Gut, wenn man jetzt so
äh stark voll formulierten Lehrplan hat, warum wird denn dieser Lehrplan immer nur in einem Klassenzimmer verkündet
an so eine kleine Gruppe, da kann man's ja auch gleich digital machen. Also das
will mir alles irgendwie nicht so richtig im Kopf. Ich sehe ein, die sind äh äh alle total überfordert und jetzt waren sie irgendwie dreißig Jahre lang ganz stolz, nicht digital zu sein. Und jetzt wollen sie es auf einmal sein. Äh klappt natürlich nicht von heute auf morgen, kriegst ja irgendwie die ganze Lehrerschaft.
Die ganzen Schulverwaltungen nicht mal ebenso digitalisiert, insbesondere, wenn sie dafür keine Mittel, keine Administratoren, keine Schulung und vor allem natürlich auch keine Erfahrung haben. Klar,
geht ja hier auch nicht ums Planegame, es geht nur dadrum, wie müsste es halt eigentlich laufen und wer halt schon mal ganz praktisch, wenn man jetzt langsam mal äh dazu übergehen könnte, äh sich zumindest dahingehend vorzubereiten und dann,
eben auch Kindern zu ermöglichen, auch mal fern zu bleiben oder auch einfach zu sagen, ich gehe heute einfach mal nicht in die Schule wegen.
Ich habe ein schlechtes Gefühl so in dieser Zeit, ne. Dazu kommt ja noch, dass es auch gar nicht mal nur die Schule ist, sondern es ist natürlich auch teilweise der Schulweg, der ist bei manchen Kindern halt auch sehr lang.
Gibt Kinder in Berlin, das sind nicht wenige, die müssen jeden Tag eine Dreiviertelstunde hier äh durch den Verkehr durch, einmal quer äh durch die Stadt
weil sie halt kein Gymnasium in der Nähe zugeteilt bekommen haben, weil hier einfach zu wenig Gymnasien sind, ne.
Ich mein das könnte natürlich auch.
Sagen das Ding sein oder das könnte der Grund sein nachdem ich vorhin gesucht habe, nämlich was unterscheidet irgendwie die Jüngeren von den Älteren
und könnte sein, dass die Älteren äh deutlich mehr ÖPNV nutzen äh äh müssen.
Also U-Bahn oder Straßenbahn oder Bus fahren um zu ihrer Schule zu kommen während Großteil der jüngeren äh halt in der in der Nähe eine Grundschule hat auf die sie gehen.
Grundschule ist es in der Regel im selben Block, ne? Und äh Gymnasien sind halt in Berlin. Also wie gesagt, es gibt Kinder, die sind eine Stunde, jeden Tag.
In die eine Richtung und eine Stunde in die andere Richtung unterwegs und müssen zwei Stunden ihres Tages quasi nur dafür opfern zur Schule zu kommen,
und das äh ja gut. Also ich will jetzt hier nicht eine allgemeine Schulkritik ähm übergehen. Hier geht's ja sozusagen jetzt erstmal darum, wie es mit Maßnahmen ist. Das haben wir jetzt auch irgendwie auch alles genannt.
Ein äh Feedback vielleicht noch aus den äh Kommentaren zum Thema Schnelltests ähm von Peter.
Er schreibt ähm äh sehr oft wird in der Cowit-Diskussion von euch auch zu Beginn der Episode der PCR-Test als Goldstandard, der Kurvetestung dargestellt. Es ist ja auch der Test, der am sichersten eine Kowitinfektion.
Nachweist.
Allerdings ist ja außer für schwer symptomatische Erkrankungen, die Infektion gar nicht entscheidend, sondern es ist die Infektion, die das Problem ist. Hier ist der PCR-Test, wie ihr richtig sagt, übersensitiv und so gesehen einem Antigenstelltest unterlegen. Vor allem ist er aber.
Einem häufig beispielsweise täglich wiederholten Antigentest unterlegen. Selbst wenn dessen Sensitivität unter der eines PCR liegt.
Mhm.
Es ist auch nicht so, dass ein Antigentest nicht auch selbständig vorgenommen werden könnte. Die Ergebnisse sind dabei nicht unbedingt ungenauer als bei den Tests, die durch
ausgebildetes Personal abgenommen werden. Also ich habe mir jetzt äh Schnelltests besorgt. Ich habe jetzt mal so ein Paket bei mir auf dem Tisch. Ich hab's noch nicht zur Anwendung gebracht. Ich äh hatte andere Prioritäten. Äh ich hatte allerdings auch Schiss, weil
Schnelltest machen, heißt zwingend die Probe durch den Nasenraum zu entnehmen.
Und während so ein Prober am Rachenraum äh schon so dieses
Problem hat, dass man also die ganze Zeit diese Würgereflex auslöst, muss man sich halt jetzt äh für diese Schnelltest auch noch so direkt so am Hirn schaben und da fahre ich bisher doch zu weicheich, um das zu machen, aber ich werd's
äh trotzdem demnächst mal probieren.
Ja, Verweis auf jeden Fall hier noch auf einen Artikel, der vor drei Monaten erschienen sei, der EP-Dimeologe der Harvard University Michael Mina, auf den der Artikel umfangreich Bezug nimmt, hat seine Position zur Produktion von selbst durchgeführten, antigen Schnelltests seitdem nicht geändert.
Ich bin ratlos, warum diese Idee nicht weiter verfolgt und nicht intensiver diskutiert wird, meinetwegen auch, warum das nicht funktioniert, et cetera, PP, wir sollten das doch mal aufgreifen. Ja.
Gut.
Ja da passt doch ganz gut zu der Nachricht, die heute auch durchs äh Internet ging äh über Matrix vier. Die Party in Potsdam.
Äh ja, das musst du mal erzählen, das habe ich noch nie mitbekommen.
Ja, na ja, es ist wohl so, dass äh ja jetzt äh Matrix vier so in Studios Babelsberg, Potsdam,
fertig produziert wurde und sie einen letzten Drehtag angesetzt haben, wo eine.
Große Party gefilmt werden sollte und.
Angeblich wurde aber gar nicht gefilmt, sondern nur eine große Party gefeiert. So und
offiziell waren dann die Gäste, waren halt alle als Komparsen geladen
So und die Empörung ist natürlich groß. Wir können irgendwie diese Privilegierten in Zeiten von Kurvit irgendwie einfach eine verbotene Party äh dort feiern, die wir als Drehtag äh getarnt ist.
Was sie aber auch gemacht haben,
ist das jeder, der äh dort äh dann teilnehmen wollte, einem Schnelltest unterzogen wurde.
Und ich halte das äh äh durchaus für eine.
Vermutlich sehr wahrscheinlich praktikable Maßnahme die doch das Risiko von Supersprading.
Auf jeden Fall äh deutlich reduzieren sollte, weil natürlich diese.
Antigenschelltests brauchen halt 'ne große Virusmenge und für 'n super Spreadder brauchst du auch 'ne Person.
Die halt in größerer Zahl Viren,
ausscheidet, das heißt die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du auch eine solche Person, die halt sehr infektiös ist mit dem Antigenschnelltest äh auch identifizieren kannst
so denke ich ist
sehr, sehr hilfreich. Es könnten zwar vielleicht der eine oder andere durchrutschen, der vielleicht gerade nicht so viel Virus ausscheidet oder nicht mehr so viel Virus ausscheidet
äh so, aber da kann man dann eben auch sagen, okay, von denen geht aber dann auch weniger Risiko aus oder
eigentlich nicht das Risiko von Superstrading so und wahrscheinlich war's weniger gefährlich an dieser Party teilzunehmen, wo alle Teilnehmer einen Schnelltest hatten, als im Supermarkt einkaufen zu gehen, wo,
Ich weiß, dass statistisch in dem
Supermarkt, äh wenn ich da reingehe, vielleicht sagt man immer morgens einkaufen, äh fällt mir gerade ein, um das Risiko auch zu minimieren.
Absolut.
So aber wenn ich jetzt abends einkaufe kann ich davon ausgehen dass in dem Supermarkt zig infizierte sich aufgehalten haben.
Vor mir. Ähm.
Dass dann ja äh die Masken und die Belüftung und so weiter ähm ja
dann hinreichend viele Viruspartikel oder Kopien von mir abhalten, aber ich,
bin mir hundertprozentig sicher, wenn du irgendwie mit.
PCR und Swobs äh äh abends äh über einen Filter, über einen Abluftfilter gehen würdest im Supermarkt, dass du da Corona findest in jedem.
Supermarkt im Moment, ja?
Also meine Corona Warnap zeigt mir auch immer wieder Begegnungen mit niedrigem Risiko an, wo sie also definitiv Leute, die sich in meiner Umgebung befunden haben äh positiv gemeldet haben und die fürs hier ist ehrlich gesagt, ich, wo die sonst mir begegnet sein sollen, als in,
dem Supermarkt.
Ja, also ich bin jetzt wieder auf zwei andcounters Lowrisk runter, ja.
Und ich kann's mir auch nicht anders äh erklären, wobei wir vielleicht dann ja, ja, in Zukunft ein bisschen besser Bescheid wissen werden, wenn uns die Corona Warn-App ein paar Informationen.
Mehr liefert, aber.
Ja, also Schnelltests, äh also ich finde, grundsätzlich dieses dieses Beispiel oder äh ja, dass ähm und ich glaube, dass auch Christian Drosten
sowas schon mal erwähnt hat in Podcast, dass man halt ja.
Bei einer neuen Strategie oder mit neuen Strategien halt eben auch schnell Tests
einbeziehen sollte und dann zum Beispiel grundsätzlich Personen,
Beispiel die innen Altersheimen oder in ein Krankenhaus zum Besuch kommen, dass da jeder einem Schnelltest äh unterzogen wird und äh dass auch medizinisches Personal mindestens zweimal die Woche äh
'nem Schnelltests äh unterzogen wird und.
Schulen, wird man natürlich gucken, vorausgesetzt es gäbe genügend Schnelltests, könnte man natürlich auch sagen, okay, ähm.
So man testet äh einmal die Woche,
mit Schnelltests oder vielleicht alle so zweimal die Woche, mit Schnelltest, wie auch immer und kombiniert das Ganze dann noch mit online offline äh Unterricht, äh sodass wenn man,
Testfrequenz jetzt reduzieren möchte. Also da gibt's glaube ich auf jeden Fall viele Möglichkeiten und Ansätze, die aber im Moment unter anderem auch deswegen nicht dienen, weil.
Keine Grundlage gibt, keine gesetzliche bisher für die Anwendung dieser,
schnell Tests, also sprich äh äh rech rein rechtlich gesehen oder gesetzlich gesehen, soweit ich weiß, ist dieser Schnelltest bisher,
komplett bedeutungslos. Ich kann mich ja mit so einem Schnelltest nicht frei testen lassen von meinen.
Quarantäne ja Auflagen, wenn ich welche habe, wenn ich aus dem Ausland komme oder so, ja, also offiziell,
gibt's den gar nicht, den Schnelltest bisher. Ja.
Na gut, also er existiert, ich weiß es äh und nicht nur einen, es gibt ja mehrere Hersteller mittlerweile, die auf dem Markt sind und ähm
Ja, also diese konkrete Verfügbarkeit, dieser Test mir nicht klar, aber wenn Slowenien in der Lage ist, äh mal eben so die Hälfte ihrer Bevölkerung schnelltest durchzuchecken, dann kann man jetzt auch nicht sagen, es gibt die nicht.
Sind schon vorhanden. Na ja, egal. Kommen wir doch vielleicht mal so ein bisschen zum High Level View. Ich habe einen Artikel entdeckt von.
Thomas Pullio, ich hoffe, ich spreche das korrekt aus, ein Franzose und der ist schon dadurch bekannt geworden, dass er.
Ähm diesen ähm diesen Artikel mit the hammer and the Dance rausgebracht hat, also er hat diese
These, wie reagiert man jetzt als Land richtig gegen eine Pandemie
und das ist auch von Christian Rosten äh tausendfach schon zitiert worden schon am Anfang, ne? Hemmer sozusagen, wir wissen nicht, wo jetzt eine Infektion herkommt. Wir wissen auch nicht,
sie schon gestreut ist. Wir wissen nur, sie ist da, sie nimmt zu und wir wissen auch nicht so ganz genau, wie eigentlich jetzt die Bedrohung konkret wirkt
wie so ein Virus überspringt, was eigentlich die wirklich die gefährlichen Handlungen sind, was wir unterbinden müssen, um es besser zu machen, aber um überhaupt erstmal wieder Klarheit zu haben, erstmal auf alles draufhauen, das ist so The Hemmer und danach kommt The Dance
Und wie sich ja jetzt zeigt, haben wir den Tanz nicht so richtig gelernt, ne. Also wir haben im Prinzip ein halbes Jahr,
viel herum äh geredet und am Ende,
Maßnahmen beschlossen, die uns dann in die zweite Welle getrieben haben. Das ist insofern auch nicht besonders überraschend gewesen, ne? Das ist halt so. Und jetzt äh stehen wir da. Jetzt ist natürlich die Frage,
Wie geht's ähm weiter? Und er hat einen Artikel rausgebracht, in dem er mal so äh die richtige Strategie quasi versucht hat, festzunageln,
Und da hat sie mal wieder mit einem schönen Namen bedacht und zwar ist von der Swiss Cheese Strategie, also von der Schweizer Käsestrategie die Rede.
Und.
Fast erstmal so zusammen, was wir ja hier eigentlich auch schon, gerade auch dieses Mal wieder äh gesagt haben, USA und Europa versagen.
Ja, beim Tanzen und der asiatisch pazifische Raum macht's vor, wie's geht.
Aber auch nicht nur der, es gibt auch gute Beispiele woanders.
Einzelne Staaten in der Karibik, kriegen's gut hin, auch in Afrika, kriegen sie's teilweise gut hin und besonders leuchtendes Beispiel in Südamerika, wo es ja insgesamt schlecht läuft, Huguai.
Glaube ich auch schon mal erwähnt
Hugai hat ja auch ein relativ ähm kluge Regierung am Start, die sofort reagiert hat, sofort die Grenzen zu gemacht hat und seitdem da irgendwie eine klare Ansage gemacht hat und Rugui ist im Wesentlichen auch alles so ein bisschen wie in Neuseeland.
Und wenn man sich halt jetzt die Staaten anschaut, die eben jetzt bisher äh alles relativ erfolgreich,
gemacht haben. Es gibt gar kein klares Profil, ne? Wir hatten ja immer so diese These mit. Ja, so China, die können sich das ja äh leisten, weil die scheißen ja auf die Leute und die überwachen alles und Pipapo
Ja okay, mag sein, aber das ist nicht das einzige Erfolgsrezept, ne? Also er meint, bei den Gewinnern ist halt einfach alles dabei, Arme und Reiche starten, repressive, liberale Staaten, asiatisch, geprägte, angelsächsisch geprägte Länder
entwickelte Staaten, aufsteigende Staaten und kontinental gelegene und Inseln, ne? Also man kann jetzt an den,
starten die,
erfolgreich das Virus bekämpft haben bisher eigentlich nur festmachen, dass es vermutlich einfach an ihrer Strategie liegt und nicht an ihren Grundvoraussetzungen, die sie mitbringen und für die sie unter Umständen überhaupt nichts tun können.
Also gibt ja jetzt hier so eine Art Tanzanleitung und die Tanzanleitung teilt sich in wesentlichen,
in vier Schritte auf, zunächst einmal Infektionen von außen stoppen,
Zweitens, bei denen die kommen, die Zahl der Personenkontakte minimieren, drittens bei Kontakten die Übertragungswahrscheinlichkeit senken und viertens,
Infektion schnell erkennen und stoppen. Und hier sieht man auch schon mal ganz grob, ähm was eigentlich mit dieser Swiss Cheese-Strategie gemeint ist, also geht von Schweizer Käse aus, der halt so ähm.
Nicht, wenn man jetzt so mehrere Scheibchen aus so einem dicken Block Schweizer Käse rausschneidet, dann hast du halt die Löcher immer an einer anderen Stelle. Wenn du die vier Scheiben hintereinander legst
dann ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du von der einen Seite zur anderen Seite einfach gerade durchschauen kannst, relativ gering, weil die Löcher halt immer woanders sind. Jede Maßnahme greift auf eine andere Art und Weise mehr oder weniger gut an einer anderen Stelle. Und es ist eben genau
diese äh Kombination aus allem, die es letzten Endes bringt, ne.
Woher? Ja, weißt du, woher diese dieses Bild ursprünglich kommt mit der Switch, mit dem Swiss Cheese aus der.
Untersuchung von äh Unglücken in der Luftfahrt. So
zwar in der Luftfahrt, hast du ja auch irgendwie ganz, ganz viele Sicherheitsmaßnahmen durch Redundanzen, du hast
äh auf allen Ebenen nur es irgendwie zwei Piloten, du hast Spritreserven, du hast mehrere Triebwerke äh äh dies und das und,
Die Luftfahrt ist halt extrem sicher, aber äh es kommt trotzdem gelegentlich ganz, ganz selten zu einem Unglück und,
Wenn man dann nachher guckt, bei diesem Unglück stellt man fest, dass halt alle diese Dinge, dass es irgendwie drei, vier, fünf, sechs Punkte gegeben hätte in dem ganzen Ablauf, wo eigentlich,
das Unglück hätte verhindert werden können, aber
es sind halt aber die Löcher im Käse haben in diesem Fall zufällig
alle äh so ähm miteinander korrespondiert, dass halt all diese
Scheiben, die eigentlich das hätten verhindern sollen, das nicht verhindert haben. Und hier macht man sozusagen jetzt das Umgekehrte oder hat man jetzt das umgekehrte Bild nach dem Motto, okay, wir müssen halt.
Scheiben machen oder Scheiben so aufliegen, dass wenn wir die hintereinander stapeln, dass auf gar keinen Fall oder es nur extrem möglichst selten
es ein Loch gibt, was halt komplett dann durch unseren Scheibenstapel durchgeht.
Genau,
Lohnt sich jetzt nochmal, die einzelnen Strategiephasen nochmal anzuschauen, weil der schreibt im Prinzip jetzt mal so ein bisschen zusammen, was es so äh Lessons Learns, ne? Also vieles davon wird uns jetzt nicht unbedingt neu vorkommen, aber ich fand's mal ganz interessant, dass das mal so äh in einem kompak
ein Statement wiedergegeben wurde. Also nochmal, wir haben diese vier äh Scheiben Käse. Der erste Teil äh heißt halt Zäune, Fances
Infektion von außen stoppen, also Länder müssen erstmal verhindern, dass sie sich von außen was neu reinholen, weil ne und,
das ist halt auch gerade äh in Europa das große Problem gewesen, zwar sind die Grenzen geschlossen worden, aber kaum war man sich dann wieder sicher, dass alles supi ist, ne? Haben wir also im Wesentlichen, das kann man äh virologisch äh äh nachweisen
vor allem aus Spanien irgendwie sehr viel wieder remportiert
und äh dann natürlich durch diese Reisewelle, ne, die ich nicht verstanden habe. Also ich bin äh sehr davon ausgegangen, dass einfach Reisen nur in Deutschland stattfinden äh äh dürften und würden,
dann mussten sie dann doch wieder alle nach Ibiza na ja gut, also das äh haben wir dann davon, ne? Also kann man aber auf jeden Fall was machen, also,
Entweder man stellt halt so Wände auf, sprich so Travel Ben, also hier kommt keiner rein oder eben oder beziehungsweise schließt sich auch nicht alles aus, sondern das wird sozusagen nachgelagerte Maßnahmen, die man auch kombinieren kann.
Dann eben, wenn du schon rein willst, dann eben Quarantäne.
Und äh auf jeden Fall so Checkpoints aufbauen, also die Leute auch vor Ort testen, direkt Soforttests machen, schnell Tests machen, PCR-Test machen, was auch immer. Und wenn man das macht, kann man eben eine ganze Menge verhindern.
Phase ähm sind die Social Bubbles, ja? Also bei denen,
die dann kommen und die unter Umständen trotzdem noch eine Infektion reintragen, ja, dann kann man halt äh dadurch eben,
erfolgreich sein, indem man solche Social Bubbles bildet,
schlicht und ergreifend aus dieser Grunderkenntnis, die wir jetzt mittlerweile haben, dass so zehn bis zwanzig Prozent der Kontakte einfach für achtzig bis neunzig Prozent der Infektionen verantwortlich sind. Na, also Supersprayer, Events müssen,
vermieden werden und die Maßnahmen, die sich hier bewährt haben, ist halt Veranstaltung ab einer bestimmten Größe verbieten.
Das haben wir ja gesehen, besonders gefährdete Orte berücksichtigen. Gefängnisse, Pflegeheime, Universitäten, Nahrungsmittelbetriebe.
Natürlich auch Bars, Clubs, Restaurants und private Partys, vor allem schließen, beziehungsweise verbieten.
Und er meint aber auch noch, man solle halt versuchen Lokdowns zu vermeiden und Schulen und Kitas so lange wie es geht, offen halten.
Das ist natürlich jetzt äh ne umstritten, aber hier geht's ja sozusagen dadrum, wie kann man äh effektiv hier äh antworten und,
Ich verstehe ja diese Aufregung und ich teile sie in gewisser Hinsicht haben wir ja gerade drüber gesprochen, so mit diesen offenen Schulen, ne. Nur die Frage ist, was wäre, wenn die Schulen nicht offen sind, das haben wir ja schon gehabt
und das wirft halt äh sehr viele Familien noch mehr in Probleme und äh sorgt auch dafür, dass andere Social Bubbles dann wieder äh zerplatzen,
Weil wohin mit den Kindern, ne? Also das ist dann halt einfach ein Problem, dann kannst du wieder deine Jobs nicht machen, dann entstehen wieder viele andere Probleme,
Man muss sich eben darüber Gedanken machen, wie kann man Infektionsgeschehen an den Schulen, selbst wenn sie offen haben, noch äh einschränken.
Das bringt uns dann auch zum dritten Teil da äh macht er eine,
interessante Wortschöpfung und zwar analog zu dem äh englischen Begriff Contraception, also der so für Schwangerschaftsverhütung benutzt wird, ähm schafft er das den Begriff Contra Faction.
Also sozusagen die Kontrainfektion äh sozusagen Maßnahmen, weil er meinte, es gibt dafür irgendwie kein Wort. Also es gibt irgendwie kein Wort, mit dem man,
verhindern von Infektionen ausdrücken kann. Da hat er einfach mal selber eins erfunden. Also hier geht's darum, bei Kontakten die Übertragungswahrscheinlichkeit zu senken. Und hier soll man halt einfach generell.
Die äh vier CS äh vermeiden, ne? Er meint hier Voice Crowded, Konfint Klos, Clamoris Communication, also Reden, singen, schreien, vermeiden und ähm,
halt äh möglichst nicht in geschlossenen Räumen sein, nicht äh in engen Räumen und nicht in vollen Räumen sein.
Wusstest du, dass in das Schreien in japanischen Seamparks verboten wurde.
Also wenn ihr da mit der Achterbahn in die Kurve fährst, auf keinen Fall schreien, ne? Ist nicht erlaubt. Ja, wurde viel drüber gelacht, aber wahrscheinlich auch was gebracht zu haben.
Wir hatten das ja hier auch äh bei Fußballspielen, das wie Singen verboten wurde. Na ja gut
Äh ja, dann generell wenig Zeit mit Leuten außerhalb der Social Bubble äh verbringen, klar, ne,
halt Virus nicht aus Mund und Nase entlassen, Masten tragen, Luftzirkulation herstellen, also Ventilatoren oder Luftfilter draußen sein, ist natürlich hilfreich. Und äh feindliche Umgebung,
für das Virus herstellen. Und das war eine ganz interessante äh Tabelle, die in diesem Artikel auftauchte, nämlich das wusste ich auch noch nicht.
Virus mag warme Temperaturen nicht. Generell, also das,
sich herauszustellen, dass einfach grundsätzlich höhere Temperaturen einfach für das Virus nicht gut sind und die Luftfeuchtigkeit.
Wenn die so zwischen fünfzig und fünfundsechzig Prozent liegt, also wärmere Temperaturen mit Luftfeuchtigkeit von fünfzig bis fünfundsechzig äh Prozent. Wenn's kalt ist, wiederum spielt es dann nicht so eine große Rolle.
Und äh er meint dann so, ja ideal für die Verbreitung des Virus, Fledermaushöhlen.
Kalt und feucht und ähm das äh.
Ja, ist eine interessante äh Schlussfolge, weil da kommt's ja unter Umständen auch her, dass Virus ähm und äh.
Das heißt dann aber auch wieder um Umkehrschluss, man kann eben einfach dadurch, dass man
auch die Luftfeuchtigkeit in so einem angenehmen Bereich hält, also mit so Luftbefeuchten und Räumen eine Menge erreichen, sehr trockene Räume, wiederum sind äh.
Problem und das ist ja auch im Winter generell das Problem, dass man in der Regel die Wohnung zu sehr austrocknen lässt, weil man da so reinheizt, nicht voll, nicht lüftet et cetera.
Ja und Virus natürlich nicht aufnehmen, also Masten tragen und äh in kritischen Situationen sogar Brillen tragen
Vierter Teil ist dann halt Test and Trace, also Infektionen schneller kennen und stoppen, wie gut das funktioniert, wissen wir ja. Äh die Positivrate so über drei bis fünf Prozent liegen.
Quarantäne halt für Kontakte von infizierten, klar und er meint dann auch.
Man sollte vor allem so zwei bis fünfmal so viele Kontaktverfolger haben, wie man tägliche Infektionen hat im Land.
Fand ich auch mal eine interessante äh Zahl, ne. Länder, die Strafen für Quarantäneverletzungen haben, fahren besser als welche ohne.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall eine Maßnahme, die man machen sollte und generell und damit bin ich auch äh auf der am Ende der Liste er plädiert halt für, warum werden Abwassertests nicht mehr genutzt? Haben wir auch schon mal drüber gesprochen, ne?
Untersuchung von Viruslast in äh in den Wasserwerken, äh Hunde
die man zum Einsatz bringen kann. Da hatten wir das Beispiel sowohl hier mit der Bundeswehr als auch äh in Finnland, da am Flughafen und wie wir schon drüber gesprochen haben, Schnelltests.
Ja, das ist so im Wesentlichen seine Zusammenfassung von was sind eigentlich die angemessenen Maßnahmen? Viele davon machen wir aber nicht alle.
Klingt aber im Großen und Ganzen wie äh äh off äh aus den letzten Monaten äh unserer Sendung äh äh hier.
Mein du hattest es also es ist wirklich.
Eigentlich nichts, also ich habe da jetzt nichts drin gefunden äh so an der Stelle, also kaum was gefunden.
Was wir nicht schon mal äh hier äh erwähnt hätten. Ähm wofür wir nicht, ja, seit.
Monaten äh plädieren oder werben oder wie auch immer. Aber weil du es jetzt,
erwähnt hattest, äh, das Thema äh Temperaturen und Wetter ähm ich
gucke gerade, wir sind noch gar nicht so. Für die Sendung ist noch gar nicht so lang und deswegen so diese fünf Minuten, glaube ich, sollten äh wir uns jetzt auch noch äh nehmen oder würde ich mir gerne nehmen,
um nochmal um darüber zu berichten, äh was ich auch noch in der letzten Woche gemacht habe, was ich eigentlich seit seit Monaten schon mal gerne äh machen wollte und jetzt
ja zumindest den ersten Schritt gegangen bin und da auf jeden Fall noch weitermachen werde, weil,
Mich hat halt immer interessiert das Thema Saisonalität oder welchen Einfluss hat das Wetter jetzt eigentlich oder die Temperatur.
Auf äh die Ausbreitung des Virus und
was ja so schon Gegenstand der Forschung ist. Normalerweise oder für viele andere Krankheiten untersucht ist, ist das Thema Saisonalität. So und ähm.
Als ich dann auch mal geguckt habe, was es denn da so an Forschungen äh gibt, ist mir wieder genau das.
Aufgefallen, was mir schon mal so vor Monaten aufgefallen ist, nämlich äh dass.
So Forschung oder Papers zu Infektionskrankheiten in der Regel mit einer viel höheren zeitlichen Auflösung.
Arbeiten, also jetzt bei der Saisonalität zum Beispiel wurden die sind die meisten Studien äh haben eine Auflösung von Monaten,
Einige haben eine Auflösung von
Wochenende. So, aber in der Regel äh mittelt man da oft über viele Jahre und äh guckt sich das an äh,
und ja ähm es gibt da tatsächlich sehr sehr wenig dass sich jetzt,
sagen genau an einem Ort den Verlauf der Infektion in dem Zeitraum
mit eventuell tagesgenauem Wetter und tagesgenauen Infektionszahlen und äh sagen da mal versucht Korrelation zu finden, weil.
Allzeit, ich weiß nicht, hundert Jahren zahlen in dieser Menge äh gar nicht gegeben
hat, ja? Und wenn du sowas wie einen vernünftigen R-Wert berechnen willst, brauchst du schon ein paar Millionen Leute äh von denen
dann aber auch eine ganze Menge dann erkranken und getestet werden und zeitnah erkranken und diese Situation, dieses Datenmaterial, was wir jetzt gerade durch diese Corona-Epidemie
gewinnend, ja? Das gab's halt noch nicht und deswegen gibt's da halt offensichtlich auch noch nicht so viel Forschung so. Und dann.
Bin ich jetzt einfach erstmal rangegangen im ersten Schritt, weil,
wollte halt jetzt nur einen halben Tag oder so äh spendieren und jetzt nicht ewige Zeit, sondern erstmal gucken, ist das irgendwie aussichtsreich? Habe ich mir halt die Wetterdaten von Berlin Tempelhof äh besorgt.
So von äh Anfang des Jahres bis vorgestern ähm.
Und äh hatte natürlich dann die äh und den gegenüber gestellt die äh Infektionszahlen äh in Berlin und den RW und hab.
Alles dann mal in einen Grafen gepackt, wobei äh,
natürlich was schon klar war, ist, dass eigentlich je wärmer es wird, umso weniger mag das Virus des. Die Zahlen aber, also die Grafen für jetzt die Fälle oder den Ehrwert,
sind ja genau umgekehrt so, das heißt, was ich eigentlich dann äh damit das visuell einfacher zu vergleichen ist, habe ich mir dann
Grafen nicht für die Temperatur, sondern für Kälte
eingebaut und das Ganze dann auch noch logaritmisch gemacht und Kälte war jetzt für Berlin definiert als neununddreißig Grad minus den
und das Ganze zum Quadrat genommen, weil ich das halt in den Logarithmischen Graphen gepackt äh äh habe so
Dazu habe ich und das habe ich dann eben mit dem RWT zusammen und äh mit den äh äh sieben Tage äh
Durchschnittswert an neuen Fällen. Äh ja mir mal dann angeschaut und dann geguckt.
So ist da irgendwas auffällig und natürlich,
kann man nicht erwarten, also hängt jetzt die,
Breitung nicht nur von Temperatur ab, sondern er Lockdowns, wir hatten Testregimeänderungen, wir hatten unterschiedliche Dunkelziffern und alles mögliche, was äh beeinflusst hat, aber.
Äh sagen, was ich mich gefragt habe, ist was zu erkennen, was jetzt wirklich, wo man mit bloßem Auge vielleicht sogar schon erkennen kann, dass das Wetter äh einen Einfluss gehabt hat.
Und ich hab tatsächlich mindestens zwei solcher Punkte gefunden, die wirklich rausstechen und da ich ja,
da wir uns ja auch die Entwicklung der Infe,
so das Auf und Ab speziell in Berlin ja ganz intensiv hier verfolgt haben und du erinnerst dich, als wir so ein bisschen in Panik verfallen sind so Mitte Juni als hier die Zahlen äh schon mal begannen wieder,
plötzlich in die Höhe zu schießen und wir dachten, okay, wenn das jetzt nicht irgendwie zum Stillstand kommt,
So, dann sieht's aber hier in Berlin jetzt ganz schlecht aus und wie. Und plötzlich weiß ich nicht, ob du dich erinnerst,
wie durch ein Wunder so.
Hielten die Zahlen an und gingen wieder zurück. Obwohl eigentlich gar nichts passiert ist
ja? Es wurden keine neuen Maßnahmen äh äh geändert, es es war eigentlich nicht so richtig, was gut jetzt sagen, okay, es gab vorher ein paar alte Ausbrüche hin.
Altersheimen und so, vielleicht war das jetzt nur Clustermäßig, aber.
Wenn man sich jetzt die Wetterkurve, also die Temperaturkurve äh anschaut, sieht man, dass genau.
Auf dem Piek und ich hab.
Sagen jetzt die Kurven auch so verschoben, dass sich möglichst äh jetzt die Zahl der Infektionen zum Infektionszeitpunkt und nicht vierzehn Tage hinterher,
sieht man, dass genau auf dem Gipfel der Infektion wir äh plötzlich eine Hitzewelle hatten mit Temperaturen über dreißig Grad.
Die dann auch eine Weile äh erstmal,
angehalten hat, zwar mit Schwankungen, aber wir haben sagen einen guten fünf Grad Sprung äh ungefähr äh gemacht äh mit eben ein paar richtig warmen Tagen und.
Aus meiner Sicht sieht das so aus.
Bräuchte jetzt mehr Analysen mit mehr Gegenden, wo vielleicht anderes Wetter war äh äh zu der Zeit, um da sicher zu gehen, aber das sieht so aus, als hätte uns damals in Berlin so eine Hitzewelle Mitte Juni.
Einmal den Hintern kurzzeitig gerettet oder für ein paar Wochen. So, ja, dann.
Fingen die Zahlen äh irgendwann äh wieder an zu steigen. Komischerweise auch begleitet dann durchaus
sozusagen von einem Anstieg der Kälte, da gingen die Temperaturen wieder zurück und dann äh gegen die Infektion auch wieder hoch, werden sie vielleicht auch auch so äh äh hochgegangen
und äh das war dann.
Mitte August ungefähr, Mitte August hatten sich dann die Zahlen über vier, fünf Wochen wieder deutlich hochgearbeitet und dann,
kam äh die große Hitzewelle äh Anfang August. So die äh dann mit Temperaturen bis achtunddreißig Grad hoch, so und da.
Kann man dann auch nochmal sehen, dass das zu einem Knick geführt hat, dass R deutlich runtergegangen ist und dass sich die dass die äh Neuinfektion runtergegangen sind und dann auch erstmal eine Weile so.
Geblieben sind, ja? Ähm.
Bis dann wieder kälter wurde.
Bis es dann äh wieder kälter wurde äh so, wobei da keine direkte Koordination war, da sind auch noch also
das folgt jetzt nicht direkt, da ist dann, obwohl es deutlich kälter geworden ist, sind dann die Zahlen erstmal nicht hochgegangen, sondern erst mit Verzögerung äh haben sie dann
nachgezogen und sie scheinen auch jetzt seit ja einem Monat ungefähr, seit sechs Wochen so ein bisschen entkoppelt.
Zu sein, eine Infektionszahlen sind in der Breite hochgegangen, aber das R ist runtergegangen und eigentlich müsste es aber der Theorie nach am ehesten mit einem RWT äh korrelieren, so, die die.
Temperatur oder Wetterabhängigkeit. Äh also da müsste man's dann am deutlichsten äh sehen, aber.
Auf jeden Fall also sehe ich so ein paar deutliche Indizien zumindest, äh dass so pro fünf Grad,
sagen würde machen zwischen null Komma ein und null Komma zwei fünf an
irre Wert äh aus, also Erhöhung oder Niedrig, je nachdem ob die Temperatur steigt oder fällt. Also das könnte durchaus
eine Rolle spielen ähm und wie gesagt.
Brauch noch, es ist jetzt ein erster Blick, der aber den ich aber interessant genug fand, dass mich das jetzt reizt, äh dass wir für zehn andere Orte äh zu machen und dann auch ein bisschen Statistik.
Draufzuwerfen, aber das Problem ist, dass man das mit, ich sage mal, mit reiner Statistik äh
so ähm auch nicht hinkriegt, man muss so ein bisschen näher
äh reingucken, was war denn los in der Zeit oder noch andere Daten hinzunehmen, wie,
Zahl der Tests oder ja Reisetätigkeit solche Sachen, die das natürlich auch alles beeinflussen. Das heißt, es ist jetzt nicht so nicht ganz so einfach, das zu machen, aber
dann zum Schluss äh zu kommen. Ähm.
Wenn das jetzt so sein sollte, wie ich das gerade im Moment vermute mit der Wetterabhängigkeit und dem Effekt in der Größenordnung von null Komma ein bis null Komma zwei fünf, hier fünf Grad, wobei.
Ist auch die Luftfeuchtigkeit ist, hattest du auch erwähnt äh tendenziell, also es gibt Studien, die sagen, okay, auch je, je feuchter,
desto also das das Virus eigentlich auch keine Trockenheit mag. Du sagtest jetzt gibt da so ein Sweet.
Also fünfzig bis äh fünfundsechzig Prozent. Mein der Punkt ist unter fünfzig Prozent wird's halt unangenehm sich in einem Raum aufzuhalten. Es reizt dann so ein bisschen die Atemwege, wenn du die ganze Zeit trockene Luft
atme es, des Siegen ist wahrscheinlich dort diese Angabe, aber fürs Virus könnte es sein, dass äh vielleicht knalltrockene äh.
Luft äh also heiße, trockene Luft vielleicht sogar am besten ist, um das Virus jetzt zu zu killen, aber.
Okay, also ich mein die Zahlen bezogen sich mehr auf Indoor, ne? Also das ist
sozusagen nicht Wetter in dem eigentlichen Sinne, sondern welche Situation findet man in Räumen vor, so habe ich es zumindest verstanden
ich würde auch mal sagen, also ja, interessant kann aber bestenfalls jetzt nur äh erstmal so ein, ein, ein, ein erster Hinweis
sein, wo es hier wirklich Zusammenhänge gib,
Ich würde ja eher vermuten, wir haben's hier mehr mit zu Schwellwerten zu tun, ne? Also nicht, dass jetzt wirklich irgendwas äh Punkt für Punkte, die im Grad hochgeht oder runter, sondern ab
Temperatur treibt sich halt einfach nach draußen, ne? Also die Leute vermeiden dann oder bevorzugen
vermeiden, dass drinnen oder bevorzugen das draußen, weil ist ja warm, warum soll man äh drin sein? Ist ja eh viel schöner und dadurch äh begibst du dich natürlich zwangsläufig mehrheitlich in der Situation, die nicht ganz so verbreitungsfreundlich ist.
Ja? Also Verhaltensänderungen, die durch Wetter bedingt sind, spielen sicherlich auch noch eine Rolle. Das ist dann auch nochmal wahrscheinlich äh,
ja ein sehr komplexer Zusammenhang, aber es gibt halt auch erstmal den rein physikalischen Zusammenhang,
zum einen Wärme des Virus inaktiviert, Sonnen- oder UV-Strahlung, das Virus,
aktiviert und auch Trockenheit äh für mehr Verdunstung äh sorgt und auch die Lebensdauer der Viruspartikel hier einfach kürzer ist, bis sie verdampft.
Sind oder die Salzkonzentration so angestiegen ist äh dass äh der Virus äh inaktiviert wird
insofern, ja, also physikalischen Effekte, aber dann auch die Effekte dann, wo halten sich die Leute wie auf, äh spielen sicherlich auch eine Rolle äh beim beim Wetter
Ähm ja, aber der Punkt, den ich eigentlich zum Schluss äh jetzt machen wollte, war der.
Ganz okay aus. Also wir hatten die letzten,
Wochen jetzt keine
deutliche Zunahme an Kälte so, also es ist es ist immer noch relativ warm und es bleibt auch noch relativ warm. Feuchtigkeit habe ich jetzt nicht gecheckt, aber der Punkt ist, dass,
wenn das Wetter sich.
So auswirkt, dann haben wir zumindest vom Wetter aktuell nichts zu befürchten. So äh das heißt, dass.
Jetzt der Logdown, der gerade läuft, einigermaßen unbeeinflusst vom Wetter sein dürfte oder vom von Wettereffekten oder nur wenig von Wettereffekten beeinflusst.
Was aber dann auch bedeuten kann, wenn denn dann doch irgendwann im November oder.
Im Dezember dann die Temperatur nochmal zurückgehen oder es feucht wird oder so, dann können wir plötzlich,
Wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, in zwei Wochen, oh, die Zahlen sind aber jetzt äh wunderbar gefallen, äh funktioniert alles ganz toll. Jetzt können wir anfangen zu lockern,
ähm oder,
Wir lockern gar nicht, aber plötzlich äh äh ändert sich jetzt das Wetter irgendwann im Dezember, dann könnte es sein, dass wir da nochmal voll in die Falle laufen und,
äh ja die Zahlen äh nochmal plötzlich äh in die schneller, in die Höhe schießen äh als wir,
uns das vorstellen können, sodass wir sagt der Punkt im Moment Wetter eher neutral.
Was den Lokdown angeht, aber äh Vorsicht geboten, weil relativ warm.
Gut, wir müssen ja langsam mal äh zum Ende kommen. Ich wollte nochmal so ein paar äh Kurzmeldungen nochmal mit reinschmeißen, dass wir die erwähnt haben und die nicht äh verloren gehen. Es gab ja noch ein paar Aufreger.
Wir hatten unter anderem diese Sache mit den Nerzen in Dänemark, das ist auch wieder so eine WhatE-Fakt-Meldung, glaube ich, die so zwischendurch äh reinkommt
Dort kam es zu einem Corona-Virusausbruch und zwar auch so, dass eben von Nerzen auf Menschen. Ich glaube, zwölf Fälle sind da beobachtet worden äh kam.
Nerze, ja, wo kommen die hin? Auf einmal alle her und warum warum sind die so gefährlich? Hm erstens Dänemark.
Ist der größte Nerzproduzer, also Nerz Fellproduzent muss man sagen, ja, weil dafür werden die Tiere ja gehalten. Die haben da also Millionen an äh Ner.
Mehr Nerze als Einwohner.
Das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, aber fünfzehn Millionen Einärzte war, glaube ich, die Zahl, ja, kann sein, ja. Sie haben, glaube ich, mehr Mehrzahl, denn.
Sich im März Mark umbenannen und ähm ja äh der Virus äh,
Das Virus der Virus. Es ist nicht immer noch nicht festgelegt, glaube ich. Also das Virus,
ist da auch ganz freudig vor sich hin mutiert, mehr als es das bei Menzen tut, das war wohl auch nicht sonderlich überraschend. Das ist wohl so mit äh Nerzen, Nerzer haben ein Immunsystem, was,
Ausgründe ich jetzt nicht benennen kann, aber so habe ich das gehört.
Einerseits dem Menschenrecht ähnliches, aber andererseits irgendwie auch äh sozusagen mutationsfreudigeres ein mutationsfreudigere Umgebung darstellt für das Virus
Ähm ja und jetzt ist die Frage, was soll gemacht werden? Die denen wollen jetzt erstmal alle Nähte da keulen.
Ob sie dann sozusagen auch die Nerzucht aufgeben, das äh sage ich mal zu zweifeln, allerdings in den Niederlanden ist das jetzt wohl,
beschlossen worden. Da macht die Netzwucht wohl nicht so einen großen Anteil aus und man will das künftig mal sein lassen, weil das eben einfach ein riesiges Virusreservoir ähm.
Ne, also hast halt quasi Millionen an Nerzen und dann kannst du sozusagen in der Gesellschaft noch so viel Virus totschlagen mit,
sperren und was nicht alles, diese Nerze reichen, also permanent dieses Virus untereinander äh weiter und dann kann sich das sozusagen über Wochen und Monaten
nur halten, sondern eben auch noch äh weiter mutieren und das ist natürlich eine rot große Gefahr und da haben sie dann halt jetzt mal beschlossen äh draufzuhalten. Na gut.
Übrigens fünf Komma acht Millionen hat Einwohner hat Dänemark und fünfzehn Millionen Nazi waren's also fast.
Nerze pro Person sozusagen. Mhm.
Das hat mich auch umgehauen. Definitiv, ja.
Gut, dann vielleicht zum Schluss nochmal ein kurzer äh Aus,
und zwar wird sich bei der Kroner Warnapp demnächst wohl was verändern, weil sich nämlich an diesen Frameworks was verändert, also das Exposé Motification Framework
ja die Kroner Bahn App und viele andere äh Warnapps äh weltweit basieren, vor allem in Europa.
Die haben nämlich jetzt ähm ein Update bekommen und es gibt quasi so eine Version zwei dieser Notification AP
diese ganze Berechnungsmethode, wie denn das, wie denn die Gefahr berechnet wird. Ähm
neu aufsetzt. Das ist ähm.
Ganz anderes Modell als man vorher gehabt hat, also offensichtlich haben sie da nochmal kräftig darüber nachgedacht.
Das Ganze, also dieser Value, der dabei äh berechnet wird, der ähm berechnet sich jetzt sozusagen ganz äh anders, indem man eben.
Verschiedene Abstandssignale zusammen zusammenrechnet.
Und äh unterschiedlich äh gewichtet auch mit äh
entsprechende Parametern von Infektisität und so weiter und dann werden da sogenannte Miningfull Expoja Minutes bei rausgerechnet, ja?
Das äh ist im Detail jetzt wahrscheinlich auch gar nicht so interessant, dass jetzt hier äh wiederzugeben. Äh Tatsache ist, es wird so eine Version zwei null geben
und die Berechnung wird eben anders aussehen und äh ganz offensichtlich ist es so, dass äh hier an diesem ganzen Framework noch weitergearbeitet wird
Es gab ja auch verschiedene Ankündigungen, dass diese Weiterentwicklung auch weiter betrieben werden soll und das soll dann so in den nächsten Monaten stattfinden, ne? Also jetzt diese Umstellung auf diese Version zwei soll wohl
im Laufe des Novembers umgesetzt werden, könnte also schon mit der nächsten äh Aktualisierung der App stattfinden.
Und äh dann halt auch mit äh häufigeren Daten abgleichen, ne? Also diese unsägliche Abholung einmal pro Tag. Das ist ja so ein bisschen wie das Gesundheitsamt in Hamburg, ne? Wurde dann immer
den entscheidenden Moment äh verpassen kannst. Das wird dann äh eben auch nachgebessert. Ja und dann äh schauen wir mal, ob,
dieser Vektor noch weiter uns helfen kann in der Bekämpfung. Dieser Pandemie. Ansonsten gibt's ja noch den
den tollen Impfstoff, da haben wir jetzt äh nicht drüber gesprochen, weil da habe ich jetzt in der letzten Sendung mit dem Lars Fischer schon drüber gesprochen, wer die Sendung vielleicht übersprungen hat, kann er da nochmal reinhören, die ist auch nicht so lang
wie dieser Wirkstoff eigentlich genau funktioniert, also wie das da so biochemisch
abläuft, was da so attackiert wird und welche Aussichten das Ganze hat, äh ist es sicherlich noch ein bisschen zu früh, um wirklich zu jubeln, andererseits sind die.
Daten diese Zwischenstände, die jetzt verkündet wurden schon recht gut. Also es sind.
Interessante Zahlen, wenn die sich bestätigen, insbesondere diese neunzig Prozent Wirksamkeit bei symptomatischen Fällen.
Wenn das klappt und wenn man wirklich diesen Wirkstoff effektiv in die Bevölkerung bekommt, dann würde es diese Ausbreitung wirklich abschwächen.
Also ich habe die Sendung jetzt noch nicht gehört, welch aber auf jeden Fall machen, was ich nur verstanden habe.
Das zum einen so aussieht als wenn Impfstoffe deutlich besser funktionieren.
Dürften, als wir es von Grippeimpfstoffen kennen, die ja notorisch problematisch sind.
So ähm und der zweite Punkt war, dass man ähm,
sagen jetzt nicht genau weiß oder wissen kann wie viele
Erkrankungen äh äh wie viele Infektionen es jetzt äh verhindert äh ähm wegen
Testmethodik und
ethischen äh äh Problemen äh so äh glaube ich war das so, dass dass man dann halt, sagen nur auf Symptome äh ge.
Äh oder gucken kann, ist das habe ich das richtig verstanden äh für die Validierung sozusagen, dass dass es um Krankheitsvermeidung geht
Aber dass man nicht genau weiß, inwieweit das mit einer Vermeidung einer Infektion einhergeht.
Na ja, nein, du hast ja im Prinzip immer diese zwei Testgruppen. Du hast also eine Placebo-Gruppe und du hast sozusagen die, die wirklich den Impfstoff bekommen haben und dann schaust du halt in diesen beiden Koorten
wie sich das dann eben verhält. Und es ist jetzt nicht so, also es sind ja irgendwie was weiß ich, zehntausende sind da ja äh haben ja teilgenommen an diesem Programm. Also eine sehr große Zahl an Leuten und was halt nicht gemacht wurde
ist, dass diese Leute regelmäßig einmal die Woche einen PCR-Test geliefert haben. Weil nur dann könntest du ja auch asymptomatische Fälle.
Überhaupt entdecken. Also man hat sozusagen nur Leute, die wirklich krank geworden sind
oder zumindest Krankheitssymptome äh hatten, ja wo man dann getestet hat und gesagt hat, aha, okay, hier Virus, die hat man zählen können und bei dem Vergleich war es dann eben so, dass eben in der geimpften Gruppe
neunzig Prozent äh weniger Fälle auftraten.
Und das ist eine relativ hohe Zahl. Also schon bei dreißig, vierzig oder fünfzig Prozent hätte man schon von einem halbwegs wirksamen Impfstoff gesprochen,
Also mal zum Vergleich der der Mumps im Stoff, der vergeben wird, der liegt so bei,
achtzig Prozent Wirksamkeit. Das heißt, selbst wenn man diese Impfung erhalten hat, heißt es nicht, dass man diese Krankheit nicht bekommen kann.
Und äh als,
Mit achtzig Prozent Wahrscheinlichkeit ist man geschützt, aber kann eben auch, man kann eben auch zu diesem Fünftel gehören, diese nehmen trotzdem noch infiziert werden äh und äh hier
zeichnet sich das so ab. Das Ding ist, es sind halt bisher noch keine wissenschaftlichen Daten rausgegeben worden, diese Veröffentlichung, die stattfand, fand halt eigentlich eher statt, weil sie eben so als Aktienunternehmen äh
genötigt sind rechtlich dann ihren Shareholder sozusagen, wenn sozusagen
Geschäftsprozessrelevante Ergebnisrelevante Dinge vorfallen. Da hast du einfach so eine Mitteilungspflicht und in dem Rahmen haben sie dann sozusagen schon mal die Türen Spalt geöffnet
aber das ist nur ein Zwischenergebnis
Das Endergebnis steht noch aus und wenn's halt so weitergeht und das alles bestätigt wird und das könnte wohl so in den nächsten Wochen der Fall sein, weil sie ja unter anderem USA testen und dort halt also wirklich genug.
Fälle sozusagen auch auftauchen, sodass man das eben ganz gut vergleichen kann
dann würden sie dann eben die Zulassung äh anstreben und wenn sie die dann auch erhalten, wovon natürlich dann auszugehen ist
dann könnte es im Prinzip losgehen, dann ist eben noch das Problem der Verteilung dieses Impfstoffs gegeben, weil diese äh RNA
Impfstoffe müssen halt extrem gekühlt werden oder zumindest weiß man noch nicht sicher, wie sehr sie gekühlt werden, deswegen geht man jetzt erstmal von so einer Maximal
kühlung aus und dann hast du natürlich entsprechende Distruptionsprobleme.
Plus, was wir halt, was natürlich auch noch nicht äh was man auch noch nicht weiß,
ist äh wie lange die Immunisierung anhält, so das sind ja auch die Befürchtungen, okay, was passiert eigentlich, wenn das nur für drei Monate oder so anhält äh und ja, Leute, alle drei Monate impfen äh müssen, dass
würde natürlich auch für gewisse Probleme.
Sagen äh dann bei der ganzen Logistik und bei der Bekämpfung. Aber hoffen wir mal
dem nicht so sein wird und dass die Impfung doch dann für eine deutlich längere Zeit für eine Immunisierung sorgt.
Das weiß man natürlich nicht, weil solange ist dieser Impfstoff ja noch überhaupt gar nicht unterwegs, ne? Also ganz klar, aber ich glaube, die einhellige Vormeinung ist, dass.
Man schon von längeren äh Immunisierungen ausgeht. Ne, also das.
Dieser Impfstoff löst ja im Prinzip wirklich auch die maximale Immunantwort aus, also da werden so richtig so Teezellen, Fressellen
erzeugt, also wirklich das, was den, den Virus auch am stärksten angeht und bisher,
ist halt die Beobachtung von natürlichen Infektionen, wie sich da das Immunsystem verhält.
So dass man eben wohl davon ausgeht, dass es mindestens ein halbes Jahr ist, also glaube drei Monate, das lässt sich derzeit nicht belegen. Ich meine, insgesamt kann man ja jetzt da eben dieser Virus gerade mal seit äh zehn Monaten in der Welt ist.
Können wir da noch nicht so viel zu sagen. So, aber bisher geht man eher von einer längeren Immunisierung aus.
Und das würde natürlich diesem Impfstoff auch in die Hände spielen. Das ist also auf jeden Fall.
Wenn das funktioniert, sind sie auf jeden Fall ein Kandidat für einen Nobelpreis würde ich sagen.
Ja hoffen wir's Beste und wie gesagt so
Im Moment, also könnte sein, was die Zahlen äh angeht, dass wir jetzt äh spätestens, also entweder jetzt den Peak erreicht haben heute oder äh
nächste Woche und äh das Wetter äh wie gesag.
Äh sieht auch erstmal okay aus, sodass wir erstmal demnächst hoffentlich von rasch fallenden Zahlen ausgehen können.
Ja.
Sehr schön, damit entlassen wir euch in äh das Wochenende oder wann auch immer ihr diese Sendung gehört habt. Wir werden nächste Woche wieder für ein
Update sorgen, mal gucken, vielleicht haben wir da den, den Knick auch schon durch Schritten. Herr Lauterbach meint, na ja, also wenn das so weitergeht, dann dauert es noch sieben Wochen. Weitere Maßnahmen wären notwendig. Es wird auf jeden Fall
einiges weiteres noch zu besprechen geben. Ansonsten vielen Dank für eure Kommentare, äh keep it coming. Ja und äh.
Ja, passt auf euch auf.
Genau. Wir sagen tschüss und äh bis nächste Woche. Tschau.